A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
清凉的泉水会触动你的心弦。那汹涌的蓝色波浪既能推动你前行，也能让你平静舒缓。从密歇根的这一岸到那一岸。只需感受当下的流动。让那些广阔的湖泊、河流和溪流创造永恒的记忆。纵身跃入，让清凉在纯净的密歇根洗涤你的身心。在 Michigan.org 保持清爽。或访问我们的网站。
34-year-old Sherry Papini knew the lyrics to everything by pop singer Michael Buble well. Not only had she chosen it as her wedding song when marrying the love of her life, Keith, it was also a great pace keeper when exercising. In November 2016, the Californian mother of two had almost fully healed from a recent breast augmentation procedure. Finally feeling well enough to start jogging again, Sherry had started training for an upcoming 5K race. Still a bit rusty, she was using an app to track her progress. Wednesday, November 2 was a clear day. With her two young children in daycare and her husband at work,
34 岁的雪莉·帕皮尼（Sherry Papini）对流行歌手迈克尔·布雷（Michael Buble）的所有歌词都烂熟于心。这不仅是她与挚爱基思（Keith）结婚时的婚礼歌曲，也是她锻炼时保持节奏的绝佳伴侣。2016 年 11 月，这位加州二胎妈妈刚从最近的隆胸手术中基本康复。终于感觉身体状况良好，可以重新开始慢跑，雪莉开始为即将到来的 5 公里长跑比赛进行训练。由于还有些生疏，她正在使用一款应用程序来追踪自己的进度。11 月 2 日，星期三，天气晴朗。她的两个年幼的孩子在托儿所，丈夫在上班，
Sherry got dressed in black leggings, a pink Nike hoodie and checkered tennis shoes. She headed outside. The Papini family lived in Redding, a small city in Northern California. Their home in the rural Mountain Gate area was surrounded by flat tree-lined roads and wide open spaces that provided a pleasant backdrop for a run. Sherry connected her earbuds to her iPhone and opened her fitness app. She pressed play on her wedding song and started jogging down her driveway. Music
雪莉穿上黑色紧身裤、粉色耐克连帽衫和格子网球鞋。她走出门外。帕皮尼一家住在北加州的一个小城市雷丁（Redding）。他们在农村山门（Mountain Gate）地区的家被平坦的林荫道路和广阔的空地所环绕，为跑步提供了宜人的背景。雪莉将耳机连接到 iPhone 上，打开了健身应用程序。她按下婚礼歌曲的播放键，开始沿着车道慢跑。音乐
Later that evening, an emergency services operator received a call from Sherry's husband, Keith Papini. He'd just returned home from work and said he was freaking out because his wife wasn't there. Officers from the Shasta County Sheriff's Office quickly arrived at the couple's home. Keith explained that it was just after 5pm when he pulled into the driveway of his family's two-story home. It was the same house that Keith himself had been raised in. With its sprawling backyard, leafy surrounds and basketball ring in the driveway, it was the ideal place to raise a family. Keith approached the front door, prepared for the usual warm welcome from his boisterous 4-year-old son and 2-year-old daughter. But as he stepped inside, it was oddly quiet.
那天晚上晚些时候，紧急服务接线员接到了雪莉丈夫基思·帕皮尼的电话。他刚下班回家，说他快疯了，因为他的妻子不在家。沙斯塔县警长办公室的警官很快赶到了这对夫妇的家中。基思解释说，下午 5 点刚过，他开车驶入自家两层楼房的车道。这正是基思从小长大的房子。这里有宽敞的后院、绿树成荫的环境和车道上的篮球架，是抚养家庭的理想之地。基思走向前门，准备迎接他那 4 岁儿子和 2 岁女儿通常的热情欢迎。但当他走进屋内时，却异常安静。
Sherry Papini typically kept the family on a tight schedule and always let her husband know if anything unexpected had arisen. But Keith said the last he'd heard from Sherry was around 11am when she texted asking if he was going to be home for lunch. It had been a busy day for Keith, who worked at a Best Buy electronic store and he'd responded that he wouldn't be able to make it. Keith walked through their home. Everything appeared as normal except for a half-wrapped present addressed to him from Sherry and the kids. Inside was a handmade American flag pillow. Keith looked outside. Sherry's car was in the driveway, but there was no sign of her or the kids anywhere.
雪莉·帕皮尼通常让家里保持严格的时间表，如果发生任何意外，她总是会通知丈夫。但基思说，他最后一次收到雪莉的消息是在上午 11 点左右，当时她发短信问他是否会回家吃午饭。对于在百思买（Best Buy）电子商店工作的基思来说，那是忙碌的一天，他回复说他赶不回来。基思走过他们的家。一切看起来都很正常，除了一个半包装好的礼物，上面写着是雪莉和孩子们送给他的。里面是一个手工制作的美国国旗枕头。基思向外看去。雪莉的车在车道上，但无论哪里都没有她或孩子们的踪影。
He sent Sherry a text, but there was no response. He called the children's daycare provider and asked what time Sherry had stopped by. The daycare worker was taken aback. Sherry hadn't picked the kids up. They were still there. Keith's initial confusion quickly turned to concern. He logged in to his Find My iPhone app, which was also configured to recognize the location of his wife's device. The icon confirmed that Sherry's phone was located less than one mile away at the corner of Old Oregon Trail and Sunrise Drive. Thinking Sherry might have gone for a walk, Keith drove to the specified location.
他给雪莉发了短信，但没有回复。他打电话给孩子们的托儿所老师，询问雪莉是什么时候去接孩子的。托儿所工作人员感到很惊讶。雪莉并没有去接孩子。他们还在那里。基思最初的困惑很快变成了担忧。他登录了自己的“查找我的 iPhone”应用程序，该程序也配置为识别他妻子设备的位置。图标显示雪莉的手机位于不到一英里外的老俄勒冈小径（Old Oregon Trail）和日出大道（Sunrise Drive）的拐角处。基思以为雪莉可能去散步了，于是开车前往指定地点。
There was no one there. He called his mother to see if she had spoken to Sherry. She hadn't. Keith tried to remain calm. He told himself that Sherry might have accidentally left her phone on the roof of her car and it had fallen off during the drive. But that didn't explain why she hadn't picked up the kids. Sherry was an incredibly dedicated mother who doted on her children and it was completely out of character for her to leave them in daycare this late. Nor did she have any health conditions that could explain a sudden absence.
那里没有人。他打电话给母亲，看她是否和雪莉谈过。她没有。基思试图保持冷静。他告诉自己，雪莉可能不小心把手机落在了车顶上，开车时掉了下来。但这并不能解释她为什么没有去接孩子。雪莉是一位极其敬业的母亲，非常疼爱她的孩子，把他们留在托儿所这么晚完全不符合她的性格。她也没有任何健康状况可以解释这种突然的缺席。
Keith got out of the car and started looking around. The intersection housed all the letter boxes for the neighborhood and it was just one and a half miles from the nearest highway. Other than that, it was fairly remote. No houses were in the immediate vicinity and traffic wasn't busy. Just off the road, Keith found Sherry's iPhone in the grass. It had a crack on the front screen but was still functioning. Sherry's headphones were still connected and Michael Buble's Everything was playing on repeat. Wrapped around the headphones were several strands of long blonde hair.
基思下了车，开始四处寻找。这个十字路口设有该社区所有的信箱，距离最近的高速公路只有一英里半。除此之外，这里相当偏僻。附近没有房屋，交通也不繁忙。在路边，基思在草丛中发现了雪莉的 iPhone。它的前屏幕有裂纹，但仍能正常工作。雪莉的耳机还连着，迈克尔·布雷的《Everything》正在循环播放。耳机上缠绕着几缕长长的金发。
The same color and length as Sherry's. Officers visited the location where Sherry's phone was found. They found no signs that a struggle had taken place. Similarly, a search of the Pepini's home revealed that everything was in order and nothing appeared to have been stolen. But there was no evidence to support the possibility that Sherry had taken off voluntarily. Her purse and belongings were all accounted for and she hadn't made any significant withdrawals from her bank account. Police questioned whether Sherry could have run away to start afresh elsewhere. Keith vehemently denied this possibility.
颜色和长度与雪莉的一样。警官们走访了发现雪莉手机的地点。他们没有发现任何发生过搏斗的迹象。同样，对帕皮尼家的搜查显示一切井然有序，没有任何东西被盗。但没有证据支持雪莉是自愿离开的可能性。她的钱包和财物都在，而且她的银行账户也没有任何大额取款记录。警方质疑雪莉是否可能为了重新开始而离家出走。基思强烈否认了这种可能性。
He had known Sherry since middle school. The two had shared a kiss as teenagers but it wasn't until years later that they reconnected and a romance blossomed. Keith was immediately smitten with Sherry, a bubbly blue-eyed blonde with a luminous smile. They married in 2009 and Sherry soon left her job as a telecommunications account executive to be a stay-at-home mum. It was a position she thrived in. Sherry organised all kinds of projects and activities for her children while also being a doting wife and homemaker. She put great care and attention into everything she did, be it decorating a homemade pie, planning a birthday party for her children or maintaining her physical appearance. According to Keith, the couple had a very happy marriage.
他从中学起就认识雪莉了。两人在青少年时期曾有过一次亲吻，但直到多年后他们才重新联系上，并萌生了恋情。基思立刻被雪莉迷住了，她是一个有着明亮笑容、蓝眼睛的金发女郎。他们于 2009 年结婚，雪莉很快辞去了电信客户主管的工作，成为了一名全职妈妈。这是一个她非常胜任的职位。雪莉为孩子们组织了各种项目和活动，同时也是一位疼爱丈夫的家庭主妇。她对所做的每一件事都倾注了极大的关怀和关注，无论是装饰自制的馅饼、为孩子们策划生日派对，还是保持自己的外表。据基思说，这对夫妇的婚姻非常幸福。
They fought occasionally but no more than any other couple. Their last argument had been a month prior over something as trivial as a messy room. Keith said there was no way that Sherry would ever voluntarily leave her children. It was a sentiment shared by others who described Sherry Papini as a super mum. In the lead-up to her disappearance, everything had been completely normal. Sherry had given no indication that she was making plans to leave or wanted to escape her responsibilities. She had recently taken her children out trick-or-treating for Halloween and was already planning what to cook for an upcoming Thanksgiving dinner. A background check revealed no known history of domestic abuse or any police call-outs to the Papini's property.
他们偶尔会吵架，但并不比其他任何夫妇多。他们上一次争吵是在一个月前，因为房间凌乱这样琐碎的事情。基思说，雪莉绝不可能自愿离开她的孩子。这种观点也得到了其他人的认同，他们将雪莉·帕皮尼描述为一位“超级妈妈”。在她失踪前夕，一切都完全正常。雪莉没有任何迹象表明她正在计划离开或想要逃避责任。她最近刚带孩子们出去参加万圣节的“不给糖就捣蛋”活动，并且已经在计划感恩节晚餐要煮什么了。背景调查显示，帕皮尼家没有任何已知的家庭暴力史，也没有任何警察接到过关于帕皮尼家财产的报警。
In fact, Keith's record was squeaky clean. Still, police had to consider the possibility that Keith was involved with his wife's disappearance. What if he had killed her and then staged a kidnapping to deflect attention from himself? Police looked into Keith's movements from Wednesday, November 2 and confirmed that he was at work all day. The last reported sighting of Sherry Papini occurred around 2pm when a neighbour saw her jogging. There had been no suspicious vehicles sighted in the area nor had anyone heard cries for help. Sherry was considered to be an alert aware person. Had someone approached her, Sherry's loved ones believed she would have put up a fight.
事实上，基思的记录非常清白。尽管如此，警方还是必须考虑基思与他妻子失踪有关的可能性。如果他杀了她，然后策划了一起绑架案来转移对自己的注意力呢？警方调查了基思在 11 月 2 日星期三的行踪，证实他整天都在上班。最后一次有人看到雪莉·帕皮尼是在下午 2 点左右，当时一位邻居看到她在慢跑。该地区没有发现可疑车辆，也没有人听到呼救声。雪莉被认为是一个警觉且有意识的人。如果有人接近她，雪莉的亲人相信她会进行反抗。
It therefore seemed more likely that whoever took her had snuck up unsuspectingly. Either that or more than one person was involved. A team searched overnight covering a half-mile radius from the corner of Old Oregon Trail and Sunrise Drive where Sherry's phone was found. An aerial search was also conducted but nothing of interest was found. The discarded iPhone was the only clue police had to go by. The following day Sherry's sister-in-law Suzanne discussed its significance in the press, saying that while it was good to have some sort of clue, it indicated that Sherry had been taken. Suzanne said,
因此，更有可能的是，带走她的人是悄悄接近的。要么就是不止一个人参与其中。一个团队彻夜搜查了以发现雪莉手机的老俄勒冈小径和日出大道拐角处为中心半英里半径的区域。还进行了空中搜查，但没有发现任何有价值的线索。被丢弃的 iPhone 是警方唯一的线索。第二天，雪莉的嫂子苏珊（Suzanne）在媒体上讨论了它的重要性，她说虽然有一些线索是好事，但这表明雪莉是被带走的。苏珊说，
She wouldn't just drop her phone if she was running away. At least it's giving us some kind of information but we're sick. This is a pretty sickening situation. The redding community was in shock. Sherry had no known enemies. Keith Pepini said there had been no strange activity such as suspicious calls or emails in the lead-up to his wife's disappearance. So who would abduct an innocent mother of two so brazenly in broad daylight just one mile from her home? The Milton Gate area was considered a safe place to live but like any other town, redding had skeletons in its closet.
如果她是离家出走，她不会就这样扔掉手机。至少这给了我们某种信息，但我们感到恶心。这是一种非常令人作呕的情况。雷丁社区感到震惊。雪莉没有已知的敌人。基思·帕皮尼说，在他妻子失踪前夕，没有任何奇怪的活动，如可疑的电话或电子邮件。那么，谁会在光天化日之下，在离家仅一英里远的地方，如此明目张胆地绑架一位无辜的二胎母亲呢？山门地区被认为是一个安全的居住地，但像其他任何城镇一样，雷丁也有不可告人的秘密。
Back in August 1998, 16-year-old Tara Smith set out for a jog down Old Oregon Trail and was never seen again. While Tara's case remained unsolved, the people of Redding had never forgotten it. Some were quick to point out in eerie coincidence. Tara Smith and Sherry Pepini had attended the same high school at the same time. They also shared a similar look, with some noting they could easily pass for sisters. Although the pair weren't known to be friends and despite 18 years passing between the two disappearances, it did spark some questions. Was it possible the same perpetrator had struck again? The sex offenders lived within one mile of the location where Sherry's phone was found.
早在 1998 年 8 月，16 岁的塔拉·史密斯（Tara Smith）出发去老俄勒冈小径慢跑，从此再也没有出现过。虽然塔拉的案件仍未解决，但雷丁的人民从未忘记。有些人很快指出这是一种令人毛骨悚然的巧合。塔拉·史密斯和雪莉·帕皮尼曾在同一时间就读于同一所高中。她们的长相也很相似，有些人注意到她们很容易被误认为是姐妹。虽然这对两人是否是朋友不得而知，尽管两次失踪之间相隔了 18 年，但这确实引发了一些疑问。是否可能是同一个作案者再次作案？性犯罪者住在发现雪莉手机地点的一英里内。
Fifty more lived in the five miles beyond. Police began looking into each individual, but one by one they were all ruled out. Meanwhile, Keith Pepini agreed to participate in a polygraph test. But he was telling the truth when he said he wasn't involved in his wife's disappearance. This, along with Keith's confirmed alibi and the lack of physical evidence linking him to the crime scene, gave police the confidence to conclusively rule him out as a suspect. Being publicly cleared provided Keith with little relief. He told People Magazine,
在接下来的五英里内还住着五十人。警方开始调查每一个人，但一个接一个，他们都被排除了。与此同时，基思·帕皮尼同意参加测谎仪测试。但他确实在说实话，他说他没有参与妻子的失踪。这一点，加上基思被证实的不在场证明，以及缺乏将他与犯罪现场联系起来的物证，使警方有信心最终将他排除在嫌疑人之外。被公开洗清嫌疑并没有给基思带来多少宽慰。他告诉《人物》杂志，
That is not where my head has been this whole time. My head has been trying to find my wife. Police continue to explore all avenues, including the possibility that Sherry might have voluntarily run away. But as the days passed with no breakthroughs, local residents became consumed by fear. They rallied behind the Pepini family, setting up a GoFundMe account to help with expenses. Missing person posters were plastered around town, urging people to be on the lookout for the 34-year-old. At a fence on the corner of Old Oregon Trail and Sunrise Drive, concerned citizens hung a bunch of helium balloons with the words, bring Sherry home, written on them.
这并不是我这段时间以来一直想的事情。我的心思一直都在试图找到我的妻子。警方继续探索所有途径，包括雪莉可能自愿离家出走的可能性。但随着日子一天天过去，没有任何突破，当地居民陷入了恐惧之中。他们支持帕皮尼一家，设立了一个 GoFundMe 账户来帮助支付费用。失踪人员海报贴满了全城，敦促人们留意这位 34 岁的女性。在老俄勒冈小径和日出大道拐角处的围栏上，忧心忡忡的市民挂了一束氦气球，上面写着“带雪莉回家”。
A $50,000 reward for information was announced. The Pepini family hired a private investigator who began working on the possibility that Sherry had been abducted as part of a human trafficking ring. The Pepini's house was only a few miles from the Interstate 5 freeway, an area known to be used for criminal activity by Mexican cartels. A trailer near their house was also a known drug den. Maybe someone frequenting the trailer had spotted Sherry and recognized her as an easy target. Police were quick to dispel this theory. Victims of sex trafficking are typically young and childless.
悬赏 5 万美元征集线索。帕皮尼一家聘请了一名私家侦探，开始调查雪莉可能作为人口贩卖团伙的一部分被绑架的可能性。帕皮尼家距离 5 号州际公路只有几英里，该地区以墨西哥贩毒集团的犯罪活动而闻名。他们家附近的一个拖车屋也是一个已知的毒窝。也许经常出入那个拖车屋的人发现了雪莉，并认为她是一个容易下手的目标。警方很快反驳了这一理论。性贩卖的受害者通常是年轻且没有孩子的。
But as others argued, Sherry looked notably young for her age. At five-foot-three inches tall with the petite 105-pound frame and long-blonde hair, some believed Sherry could pass for 18. Had she been targeted at random, it was possible the perpetrator had mistaken her for a much younger woman. By November 17, Sherry Pepini had been missing for 15 days. The FBI became involved as the local rumor mill swung into overdrive. Some theorized that Sherry could have been taken by a stalker. What if someone had been watching her movements closely and knew exactly when she'd be alone on the remote running trail?
但正如其他人所争辩的那样，雪莉看起来比实际年龄年轻得多。她身高 5 英尺 3 英寸，体重 105 磅，身材娇小，留着长长的金发，有些人认为雪莉看起来像 18 岁。如果她是随机被盯上的，作案者很有可能把她误认为是一个年轻得多的女性。到 11 月 17 日，雪莉·帕皮尼已经失踪 15 天了。随着当地谣言四起，联邦调查局（FBI）介入了调查。有些人推测雪莉可能被跟踪者带走了。如果有人一直在密切观察她的行踪，并且确切地知道她什么时候会独自出现在偏僻的跑步小径上呢？
There was also talk of a possible affair. Some speculated that Sherry could have been involved with a married man whose scorned lover had abducted her as part of a revenge plot. Despite Keith Pepini being publicly cleared, many members of the public continued to cast suspicion on him. Keith Pepini did his best to hold it together for the sake of his young children. He held onto hopes that Sherry was still alive and being held somewhere. Making a teary appeal to his wife on television, Keith said, If Sherry is listening, I want to say that we are trying. We're trying the best we can and I'm so sorry that I'm not there.
还有关于可能存在婚外情的传言。一些人推测雪莉可能与一名已婚男子有染，而该男子的嫉妒情人为了报复绑架了她。尽管基思·帕皮尼被公开洗清了嫌疑，但许多公众成员继续对他表示怀疑。基思·帕皮尼为了年幼的孩子们，尽力保持坚强。他怀揣着雪莉还活着并被关在某处的希望。基思在电视上向妻子发出泪流满面的呼吁，他说：“如果雪莉在听，我想说我们正在努力。我们正在尽我们所能，我很抱歉我不在那里。”
I love you. Addressing the perpetrator directly, Keith told People Magazine, I just want her back and I want her back safe. Just bring her home. Please bring her back. The sooner, the better. A wealthy businessman was passing through Reading when he learned of Sherry's disappearance and heard Keith's heartfelt pleas for her safe return. Something about the case struck a chord with the man. Even though he didn't know Sherry or the Pepini family, the pain they were experiencing seemed unimaginable. He began thinking about ways that he could help out.
“我爱你。”基思直接向作案者喊话，告诉《人物》杂志：“我只想让她回来，我只想让她平安回来。把她带回家。请把她带回来。越快越好。”一位富有的商人在路过雷丁时得知了雪莉失踪的消息，并听到了基思为她平安归来而发出的衷心恳求。这件事触动了这位男子的心弦。尽管他不认识雪莉或帕皮尼一家，但他们所经历的痛苦似乎是无法想象的。他开始思考自己可以提供什么帮助。
That's when the idea struck him. What about a reverse ransom? After reaching out to Keith Pepini and getting the go ahead, the businessman who chose to remain anonymous created a website titled SherryPepini.com. He made a bizarre offer to whoever had abducted Sherry. Return her safely and receive an undisclosed six-figure reward with no questions asked. The donor wrote, I am willing to pay you in whatever way you can creatively think about where you feel safe and where nothing can be tracked to you. I will not communicate with the police and sheriff's department regarding any details about this offer. Law enforcement were firmly against this tactic for several reasons.
就在那时，他想到了一个主意。反向赎金怎么样？在联系了基思·帕皮尼并获得许可后，这位选择保持匿名的商人创建了一个名为 SherryPepini.com 的网站。他向绑架雪莉的人提出了一个奇怪的提议。平安归还她，即可获得一笔未公开的六位数奖金，且不问任何问题。捐赠者写道：“我愿意以任何你能想到的创造性方式支付给你，只要你觉得安全，且无法追踪到你。我不会就此提议的任何细节与警察和警长部门进行沟通。”执法部门坚决反对这种策略，原因有几点。
For one, there still wasn't enough evidence to unequivocally confirm that Sherry Pepini had been abducted. If she had, her kidnapper had made no attempt to demand any kind of ransom. Two, releasing an offer like this left the Pepini family vulnerable to scam artists. And thirdly, financially rewarding someone for their criminal activity only served to encourage future copycats. The anonymous donor was undeterred. He hired an independent hostage negotiator named Cameron Gamble to act as his spokesman and gave a deadline of 100 hours, writing on his website, Once I leave town, this offer is off the table. Public reaction to the offer was mixed.
首先，仍然没有足够的证据明确证实雪莉·帕皮尼是被绑架的。如果她是，绑架者也没有试图索要任何形式的赎金。其次，发布这样的提议使帕皮尼一家容易受到诈骗者的伤害。第三，在经济上奖励某人的犯罪活动只会助长未来的模仿者。匿名捐赠者并没有被吓倒。他聘请了一位名叫卡梅伦·甘布尔（Cameron Gamble）的独立人质谈判专家作为他的发言人，并设定了 100 小时的最后期限，他在网站上写道：“一旦我离开城镇，这个提议就作废。”公众对该提议的反应不一。
Some viewed it as a novel way to help solve missing person cases. Skeptics believed it was nothing more than a publicity stunt for Cameron Gamble to promote his hostage negotiation business. Either way, the 100 hour deadline came and went without anyone coming forward. The donor withdrew the controversial reverse ransom offer, but said the unclaimed money would be added towards the existing $50,000 reward offered by law enforcement. By November 23, Sherry Pepini had been missing for three weeks. Investigators had chased over 400 leads and executed 20 search warrants to obtain data relating to cell phone records, social media accounts, banking information and emails. A check of Sherry Pepini's cell phone revealed she had recently deleted a text message exchange with a female contact. But when police looked into this contact, they realized it wasn't a woman at all.
有些人认为这是一种解决失踪人口案件的新颖方法。怀疑论者认为这只不过是卡梅伦·甘布尔为推广其人质谈判业务而进行的宣传噱头。无论如何，100 小时的最后期限过去了，没有人站出来。捐赠者撤回了有争议的反向赎金提议，但表示未领取的钱款将增加到执法部门提供的现有 5 万美元悬赏金中。到 11 月 23 日，雪莉·帕皮尼已经失踪三周了。调查人员追踪了 400 多条线索，并执行了 20 份搜查令，以获取与手机记录、社交媒体账户、银行信息和电子邮件相关的数据。对雪莉·帕皮尼手机的检查显示，她最近删除了一段与一位女性联系人的短信交流。但当警方调查这位联系人时，他们意识到这根本不是一个女人。
Sherry had been conversing with a man from Michigan named Donovan, but had hidden his number under a woman's name. The two had been texting between October 29 and November 1, the day before Sherry went missing. Donovan had been in San Francisco for a work conference, and the two discussed the possibility of meeting up in Reading. However, it was a five hour drive between the two cities, which Donovan deemed too far. Their rendezvous didn't eventuate, but for investigators, this was a solid lead. What if Donovan had decided to swing by Reading after all? They obtained Donovan's travel records and confirmed that he had returned to Michigan on November 2, the day of Sherry's disappearance. Investigators flew to Michigan to visit Donovan's apartment while he was at work.
雪莉一直在与一名来自密歇根州名叫多诺万（Donovan）的男子交谈，但将他的号码隐藏在一个女性名字下。两人在 10 月 29 日至 11 月 1 日（雪莉失踪前一天）期间一直在发短信。多诺万当时在旧金山参加一个工作会议，两人讨论了在雷丁见面的可能性。然而，两个城市之间有五个小时的车程，多诺万认为太远了。他们的会面没有实现，但对调查人员来说，这是一个可靠的线索。如果多诺万最终决定顺道去雷丁呢？他们获得了多诺万的旅行记录，证实他已于 11 月 2 日（雪莉失踪当天）返回密歇根州。调查人员飞往密歇根州，在多诺万上班时走访了他的公寓。
They searched the premises, but found no sign of Sherry Pepini or anything else incriminating. When police arrived at Donovan's work for an interview, he seemed shocked. According to Donovan, he had met Sherry Pepini in 2011 when she was in Michigan for a work trip. He later told the Sacramento Bee that he found her to be, quote, drop dead gorgeous. Donovan said there was something pretty magical about her. Sherry made no mention of the fact that she was married and the two had spent the weekend together. Over the years, they continued to send the occasional flirty message, but it never went beyond that. Donovan assumed the recent contact from Sherry was due to her seeing his social media post about being in San Francisco.
他们搜查了住所，但没有发现雪莉·帕皮尼的踪迹或任何其他有罪的证据。当警察到达多诺万的工作地点进行采访时，他显得很震惊。据多诺万说，他是在 2011 年雪莉去密歇根出差时认识她的。他后来告诉《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》，他觉得她“美得惊人”。多诺万说她身上有一种非常神奇的东西。雪莉没有提到她已婚的事实，两人度过了一个周末。多年来，他们偶尔会发送一些调情的短信，但从未超越过这一点。多诺万认为雪莉最近的联系是因为她看到了他在社交媒体上发布的关于他在旧金山的消息。
Donovan denied being anywhere near Reading on the day Sherry went missing. He had data on his cell phone to prove he was in San Francisco at the time and others were able to confirm his alibi. For investigators, this was a major blow. It was back to the drawing board. Thursday, November 24 was Thanksgiving Day. What was typically a day of celebration for the Pepini family was now a stark reminder that 22 days had passed with no sign of Sherry. Before her disappearance, she'd been enthusiastically making plans with her in-laws about the day. She'd intended on making sweet potatoes, her children's favorite. Instead, members of the Reading community planned to gather later in the afternoon to show support for Sherry's loved ones.
多诺万否认在雪莉失踪当天出现在雷丁附近。他手机上的数据证明他当时在旧金山，其他人也能够证实他的不在场证明。对调查人员来说，这是一个重大打击。一切又回到了原点。11 月 24 日星期四是感恩节。对于帕皮尼一家来说，这通常是一个庆祝的日子，但现在却是一个严酷的提醒：22 天过去了，依然没有雪莉的踪影。在她失踪前，她曾热情地与公婆计划这一天。她打算做红薯，这是孩子们的最爱。相反，雷丁社区的成员计划在下午晚些时候聚集在一起，以表达对雪莉亲人的支持。
Keith Pepini got up before dawn to begin his day. He was in the bathroom shaving when his phone rang. On the other line was one of the detectives working on his wife's case. They finally had news. Sherry Pepini had been found. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky barbecue glaze and topped with a creamy barbecue sauce. Can't picture it? Well, you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new barbecue crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. By 4.30am on Thanksgiving morning, traffic was already busy on the Interstate 5 highway in Yolo County, a rural area 140 miles south of Reading. As motorists made their way to celebrate the holiday with friends and family, several passers-by noticed something strange on the side of the road.
基思·帕皮尼在黎明前起床开始他的一天。他正在浴室刮胡子时，电话响了。电话那头是负责他妻子案件的侦探之一。他们终于有了消息。雪莉·帕皮尼被找到了。新鲜烹制的脆皮调味鸡肉，裹上烟熏烧烤酱，并淋上奶油烧烤酱。想象不出来吗？好吧，你现在可以在蒂姆（Tim's）尝试一下。在有限的时间内购买我们新的烧烤脆皮鸡肉碗和卷饼。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供优质内容。感恩节早晨 4 点 30 分，位于雷丁以南 140 英里的农村地区约洛县（Yolo County）的 5 号州际公路上，交通已经很繁忙。当驾车者前往与亲朋好友庆祝节日时，几位路人注意到路边有些奇怪。
Through the darkness, a panicked looking woman was frantically waving a piece of fabric in the air as though trying to attract attention. Unsure what to make of it, many continued onwards. One woman pulled over a little further down the highway to call 911 while a truck driver pulled over and addressed the woman directly. In a state of distress, she told him her name was Sherry Papini and that she needed an ambulance. She was covered in bruises and said that her vision was blurry. Around her waist was a metal chain. First responders arrived promptly and were shocked by what they saw. The woman who stood before them was a severe contrast to the vibrant smiling face that had been plastered on posters and news bulletins. Sherry Papini was dressed in dirty grey sweatpants, a sweatshirt and socks.
在黑暗中，一名看起来惊慌失措的女子正疯狂地挥舞着一块布，似乎想引起注意。许多人不知道该怎么办，继续前行。一名女子在高速公路前方一点停下车拨打 911，而一名卡车司机停下车直接与该女子交谈。她处于痛苦状态，告诉他她的名字是雪莉·帕皮尼，她需要救护车。她浑身是伤，说她的视力模糊。她的腰间系着一条金属链。急救人员迅速赶到，被他们所看到的景象震惊了。站在他们面前的女子与海报和新闻简报上那个充满活力、面带微笑的脸庞形成了鲜明的对比。雪莉·帕皮尼穿着脏兮兮的灰色运动裤、运动衫和袜子。
Her waist-length blonde hair had been crudely hacked to her shoulders and she looked emaciated. She was disoriented, having no idea where she was or what day it was. There were restraints around her ankles and zip ties around her wrists, one of which was tethered to the chain around her waist. It was only upon being transferred to a nearby hospital that the full extent of Sherry's injuries became clear. Her body was covered in bruises in various states of healing, some yellow and others black and blue. The bridge of her nose was broken and there were rashes and burns all over her arms and legs. Ligature marks were visible on her wrists and ankles. She had lost a little over 10 pounds, a significant amount given she only weighed 105 pounds when she went missing.
她齐腰长的金发被粗暴地剪到了肩膀，看起来骨瘦如柴。她神志不清，不知道自己在哪里，也不知道今天是星期几。她的脚踝上有束缚，手腕上有扎带，其中一个系在腰间的链子上。直到被转移到附近的医院，雪莉受伤的程度才变得清晰起来。她的身体布满了处于不同愈合阶段的淤青，有些是黄色的，有些是青紫色的。她的鼻梁骨折了，手臂和腿上到处都是皮疹和烧伤。手腕和脚踝上有明显的勒痕。她瘦了 10 多磅，考虑到她失踪时只有 105 磅，这是一个相当大的数字。
But the most horrific injury was on her right shoulder. Burnt into her flesh were a series of undistinguishable letters, some scabbed and others already scarred. Sherry had been branded. When Keith Papini arrived at the hospital, it was a teary reunion for the couple. They hugged each other tightly for 20 minutes as Keith was overcome with conflicting emotions. Relief that Sherry had been found alive and revulsion that someone could do something so horrible. Sherry was clearly traumatized and refused to speak to the police. She told Keith that law enforcement had been involved in her abduction and she therefore didn't trust anyone.
但最可怕的伤口是在她的右肩上。烙印在她肉里的是一串无法辨认的字母，有些结了痂，有些已经留下了疤痕。雪莉被烙上了印记。当基思·帕皮尼到达医院时，这对夫妇重逢了，泪流满面。他们紧紧拥抱了 20 分钟，基思被矛盾的情绪所淹没。雪莉活着被找到的宽慰，以及有人能做出如此可怕事情的厌恶。雪莉显然受到了创伤，拒绝与警方交谈。她告诉基思，执法部门参与了她的绑架，因此她不信任任何人。
Instead, investigators gave Keith an audio recorder so that he could ask her questions himself. According to Sherry, she'd been jogging the old Oregon Trail when a dark colored SUV drove by and then backed up again. Two Hispanic women were inside. One of them beckoned her over saying they needed help with something. Sherry approached the vehicle but as she got closer, one of the women held up a small gun. She demanded that Sherry drop her phone and get into the car, reassuring her, we don't want to kill you. Thinking quickly as she removed her headphones, Sherry purposely pulled out several strands of her hair to leave behind as a clue. Sherry got into the vehicle and the women put something over her head.
相反，调查人员给了基思一个录音机，这样他就可以自己问她问题。据雪莉说，她当时正在老俄勒冈小径慢跑，一辆深色的 SUV 开过，然后又倒了回来。车里有两名西班牙裔女性。其中一个向她招手，说她们需要帮忙。雪莉走近车辆，但当她靠近时，其中一名女子举起了一把小枪。她要求雪莉扔掉手机并上车，安慰她说：“我们不想杀你。”雪莉在摘下耳机时灵机一动，故意拔下几缕头发留在身后作为线索。雪莉上了车，女人们用东西蒙住了她的头。
One of them struck her with something. Sherry thought it might have been a taser. From there, everything went hazy. She tried to stay awake but kept losing consciousness. The next thing she knew, she woke up in a strange room that had its windows boarded up from the inside. There was nothing in the room except for a bed, a dresser and a closet. All of her clothes were gone and she'd been redressed in a plain t-shirt. Sherry stood on the bed and tried to look out the window only to discover it had also been boarded up from the outside.
其中一个用什么东西打了她。雪莉认为那可能是电击枪。从那以后，一切都变得模糊了。她试图保持清醒，但一直失去知觉。下一件事她知道的是，她在一个奇怪的房间里醒来，窗户从里面被木板封住了。房间里除了床、梳妆台和壁橱外什么都没有。她所有的衣服都不见了，她被换上了一件普通的 T 恤。雪莉站在床上试图向窗外看，却发现窗户也被从外面封住了。
She attempted to dislodge one of the boards but the two women came in and caught her in the act. They yanked her down by her hair and hit her so hard that she saw stars. When Sherry came too, the dresser was gone and the bed was in its place. A chain had been tied around her waist which was bolted to the ceiling and hooked to a metal pole in the closet. Over the coming days, the two women came and went from the room. Sherry was mostly kept locked in the closet. She was given a bucket full of kitty litter to use as a toilet and fed once daily with small portions of bread, gritty rice, porridge and the occasional apple or fad off a piece of meat. Outside her door, a speaker blasted what Sherry described as, quote, that really annoying Mexican music a majority of the time.
她试图撬开其中一块木板，但那两个女人进来抓住了她。她们抓住她的头发把她拽下来，打得她眼冒金星。当雪莉清醒过来时，梳妆台不见了，床取而代之。一条链子系在她的腰上，链子被固定在天花板上，并钩在壁橱里的金属杆上。在接下来的几天里，这两个女人进进出出。雪莉大部分时间都被锁在壁橱里。她得到一桶猫砂作为厕所，每天只吃少量面包、粗米、粥和偶尔的苹果或一块肉。在她的门外，一个扬声器大部分时间都在播放雪莉所描述的“那种非常烦人的墨西哥音乐”。
The two women yelled at her in Spanish which Sherry didn't understand and the older of the two occasionally beat her. Any time Sherry made a sound, she was physically punished. She was sometimes burned with heated up kitchen utensils. When she accidentally made a clanging noise with her chain, one of the women rushed in and cut off her ponytail, threatening, I'm going to send it to your mother. Sherry wasn't particularly close with her mother so this comment led her to believe that her captors didn't know her and had taken her at random. When Sherry questioned why they were doing this, one of them said, We sell you.
这两个女人用雪莉听不懂的西班牙语对她大喊大叫，年纪较大的那个偶尔会殴打她。每当雪莉发出声音，她就会受到身体惩罚。她有时会被加热的厨房用具烫伤。当她不小心用链子发出叮当声时，其中一个女人冲进来剪掉了她的马尾辫，威胁说：“我要把它寄给你妈妈。”雪莉和她母亲的关系并不特别亲密，所以这句话让她认为绑架者不认识她，是随机绑架了她。当雪莉问她们为什么要这样做时，其中一个说：“我们卖了你。”
The other added, your buyer is a cop. The women read Sherry news articles about her disappearance. One of them laughed as she said, No one believes you. Everyone thinks you ran away. Guess what? The buyer is a cop. They're never going to find you. Sherry had no idea what to do. She tried to engage with her captors by offering to cook or clean for them in the hopes they would give her more information.
另一个补充说：“你的买家是警察。”女人们给雪莉读关于她失踪的新闻报道。其中一个笑着说：“没人相信你。每个人都认为你离家出走了。猜猜怎么着？买家是警察。他们永远找不到你。”雪莉不知道该怎么办。她试图通过主动提出为她们做饭或打扫卫生来与绑架者接触，希望她们能给她更多信息。
But the women remained tight-lipped. With Sherry's limited knowledge of Spanish words, she thought she heard mention of traffic, cameras, medicine and a delivery date. Fearful of what that signified, she began making plans to escape. At one point, Sherry's captors forced her into the shower at gunpoint and told her to wash herself. As Sherry lathered herself with coconut-centred body wash, the women became engaged in a conversation and lowered their guns. Recognizing this as an opportunity, Sherry jumped on the younger woman and smashed her head into the toilet. She slipped and cut her foot in the process. The older woman dragged Sherry back to her room by her hair, forcing an unknown substance down her throat.
但女人们守口如瓶。由于雪莉对西班牙语单词的了解有限，她以为听到了关于交通、摄像头、药物和交货日期的提及。担心这意味着什么，她开始计划逃跑。有一次，雪莉的绑架者用枪指着她强迫她洗澡，并告诉她洗干净。当雪莉用椰子味的沐浴露涂抹全身时，女人们开始交谈并放下了枪。意识到这是一个机会，雪莉扑向年轻的那个女人，把她的头撞在马桶上。她在过程中滑倒并割伤了脚。年纪较大的女人抓住雪莉的头发把她拖回房间，强行把一种不明物质灌进她的喉咙。
When Sherry made another attempt to escape, the women tied her to a table and slashed her t-shirt off from behind. Already in agony from her healing breast implants, that's when the women branded her. Sherry's captors told her this is what her buyer wanted. Along with the immense pain, Sherry heard her skin make a sizzling popping sound. Too scared to make a noise, she kept her eyes clenched shut until it was over. While it was unclear what the words said, Sherry believed it said Exodus, which she described as a really confusing Bible passage. To maintain her strength and sanity, Sherry spent some of her spare time doing yoga. She scratched away at the drywall inside the closet in the hopes she might chip a big enough hole to escape.
当雪莉再次尝试逃跑时，女人们把她绑在桌子上，从后面割开了她的 T 恤。由于隆胸手术的伤口还在愈合，她已经痛苦不堪，就在这时，女人们烙印了她。雪莉的绑架者告诉她，这就是她的买家想要的。除了巨大的痛苦，雪莉还听到她的皮肤发出嘶嘶的爆裂声。因为太害怕而不敢出声，她紧闭双眼直到结束。虽然不清楚上面写的是什么字，但雪莉认为写的是“出埃及记”（Exodus），她将其描述为一段非常令人困惑的圣经段落。为了保持体力和理智，雪莉利用空闲时间做瑜伽。她抓挠壁橱里的干墙，希望自己能凿出一个足够大的洞来逃跑。
She thought about her children constantly. Over time, Sherry sensed that the younger of her captors was starting to soften. Sometimes when the older woman beat Sherry, the younger one would drag her off. Then one day, Sherry was sitting on the bed when she heard a gunshot. Terrified, she hid in the closet. It sounded like someone was gathering up keys to leave the house. Then came the blasting mariachi music. Sherry started screaming and yanking on her chains until she eventually fell asleep.
她不断地想念她的孩子们。随着时间的推移，雪莉感觉到年轻的绑架者开始心软了。有时，当年纪较大的女人殴打雪莉时，年轻的那个会把她拉开。有一天，雪莉正坐在床上，听到了一声枪响。她吓坏了，躲进了壁橱。听起来好像有人在收集钥匙准备离开房子。然后是震耳欲聋的墨西哥流浪乐队音乐。雪莉开始尖叫并拉扯她的链子，直到最终睡着了。
When she woke up, the younger of her captors came in and gave her a plate of food. Sherry ate it, but soon started to feel nauseous and dizzy. She could barely stand. The younger captor came back in and hit Sherry in the face. She had laid a fresh sweatsuit out on the bed and insinuated that Sherry get dressed into it. Sherry did so, after which the woman hit her again and placed something over her head so that she couldn't see. Sherry was then let outside and into a vehicle. Sharp restraints were secured around her ankles and wrists, one of which was secured to the vehicle. Sherry didn't know who else was in the car. There were no voices, only the sound of the radio.
当她醒来时，年轻的绑架者进来给了她一盘食物。雪莉吃了，但很快开始感到恶心和头晕。她几乎站不稳。年轻的绑架者回来打了雪莉的脸。她在床上放了一套新的运动服，暗示雪莉换上它。雪莉照做了，之后那个女人又打了她一下，并用东西蒙住了她的头，让她看不见。雪莉随后被带到外面并被塞进一辆车里。尖锐的束缚物被固定在她的脚踝和手腕上，其中一个被固定在车上。雪莉不知道车里还有谁。没有声音，只有收音机的声音。
Sherry tried to keep track of how far they drove by counting the number of songs, but she kept falling asleep. Eventually, the car stopped. The younger captor ordered Sherry to get out. Sherry was terrified. She started crying. The woman cut her restraints, pushed her out the door and drove off. Sherry removed her head covering, realising it was a pillow case. She looked around at her rural surroundings and had no idea where she was. She began to run. Eventually, she came to a building but it was locked, so she started running down the dark highway, waving the pillow case and screaming at the top of her lungs.
雪莉试图通过数歌曲的数量来记录她们开了多远，但她一直睡着。最终，车停了。年轻的绑架者命令雪莉下车。雪莉吓坏了。她开始哭泣。那个女人剪断了她的束缚，把她推下车，然后开车走了。雪莉摘下头罩，意识到那是一个枕套。她环顾四周的农村环境，不知道自己在哪里。她开始奔跑。最终，她来到了一栋建筑前，但门锁着，于是她开始沿着黑暗的高速公路奔跑，挥舞着枕套，声嘶力竭地尖叫。
She screamed so hard that she could taste blood in the back of her throat. Car after car sped past without stopping. Sherry wondered if they could see her restraints and were deterred from stopping because they thought she was an escaped prisoner. She tried to hide them under her clothes until a trucker eventually stopped. Safe in hospital with her husband, Sherry was thoroughly examined. She was adamant that she hadn't endured any form of sexual assault. This was supported by medical exams. Toxicology tests came up clean for narcotics, ruling out the possibility that Sherry had been drugged. Her clothing was sent off for DNA testing.
她尖叫得太用力，以至于能尝到喉咙后部的血腥味。一辆又一辆车飞驰而过，没有停下来。雪莉想知道他们是否看到了她的束缚，并因为认为她是逃犯而不敢停车。她试图把它们藏在衣服下面，直到最终有一辆卡车停了下来。在医院里与丈夫团聚后，雪莉接受了全面检查。她坚称自己没有遭受任何形式的性侵犯。医学检查证实了这一点。毒理学测试显示没有麻醉品，排除了雪莉被下药的可能性。她的衣服被送去进行 DNA 检测。
On Thanksgiving afternoon, members of the Redding community gathered in Sherry's honour as plant, unaware that she'd been found alive. When the good news was revealed a few hours later, Sherry's sister Sheila thanked their supporters, saying, Everyone's tireless efforts have made our family whole again this Thanksgiving. News of Sherry's escape gripped the nation. The public were hungry for details, but the Papini family requested privacy during this time of healing. Over the coming days, investigators gently probed Sherry for any more details she could remember that might help them catch her abductors. While Sherry tried to keep things light-hearted, her trauma was obvious. She hugged her knees to her chest, her eyes mostly cast downward, as she did her best to provide every possible piece of information. The two women had worn masks over the bottom halves of their faces, so Sherry never got a complete look at them, but she remembered other details.
感恩节下午，雷丁社区的成员聚集在一起纪念雪莉，不知道她已经被活着找到了。几个小时后，当好消息传出时，雪莉的妹妹希拉（Sheila）感谢了他们的支持者，她说：“每个人不懈的努力使我们的家庭在这个感恩节再次团聚。”雪莉逃脱的消息震惊了全国。公众渴望了解细节，但帕皮尼一家要求在这一康复期间保持隐私。在接下来的几天里，调查人员温和地询问雪莉是否还能想起任何有助于他们抓住绑架者的细节。虽然雪莉试图让事情变得轻松，但她的创伤显而易见。她双膝抱胸，眼睛大多低垂，尽其所能提供每一条可能的信息。那两个女人在脸的下半部分戴着面具，所以雪莉从未看清她们的全貌，但她记得其他细节。
The older of the pair had a long, straight dark hair that was showing signs of graying. She had dark eyes and thick, bushy eyebrows. She was roughly three inches taller than Sherry, heavyset, and spoke with a raspy voice. Her breath smelled like sweetened coffee. The younger woman had dark curly hair that had been smoothed with product, thin, over-tweased eyebrows, and wore large hoop earrings. She was a bit shorter than Sherry, with a slightly muscular build and hairy arms. Sherry struggled to record details about the clothing either of the women had been wearing, other than the fact they always wore leather gloves. The pair fought often, and Sherry regularly overheard the older woman hit the younger one. As for the location where she was held, Sherry had no idea. She sometimes heard birds outside, but because of the speaker outside her door, she never heard anything else.
年长的那位留着长长的直黑发，已经开始显露灰白。她有着深色的眼睛和浓密粗糙的眉毛。她比雪莉高出大约三英寸，身材魁梧，说话声音沙哑。她的呼吸闻起来有甜味咖啡的味道。年轻的那位留着深色卷发，头发用护发产品梳理得很顺滑，眉毛很细，修剪过度，戴着大圆环耳环。她比雪莉稍矮，体格略显强壮，手臂上有汗毛。雪莉很难记录下这两个女人穿的衣服细节，只记得她们总是戴着皮手套。两人经常吵架，雪莉经常听到年长的女人殴打年轻的那个。至于她被关押的地点，雪莉毫无头绪。她有时能听到外面的鸟叫声，但因为门外有扬声器，她听不到其他任何声音。
It was always cold, possibly raining every night, and she could smell a fireplace. Any time she made a noise, her captors came in and took her blankets away as punishment. The bathroom had a unique layout which Sherry was able to describe in detail, right down to a crack in the shower tile. She never saw the outside of the building. To maintain the integrity of the investigation, police made the strategic decision to withhold details about Sherry's time in captivity, including the branding. But this silence led to speculation from cynics that the whole kidnapping had been a hoax. If the police were so vocal about seeking answers when Sherry went missing, why go quiet when she was returned safely? Was it possible the whole thing had been a publicity stunt by Cameron Gamble, the hostage negotiator after all?
那里总是很冷，可能每天晚上都在下雨，她能闻到壁炉的味道。每当她发出声音，绑架者就会进来拿走她的毯子作为惩罚。浴室的布局很独特，雪莉能详细描述出来，甚至连淋浴瓷砖上的裂缝都记得。她从未见过建筑的外部。为了维护调查的完整性，警方做出战略决定，隐瞒雪莉被囚禁期间的细节，包括烙印。但这种沉默导致愤世嫉俗者猜测整起绑架案是一场骗局。如果警方在雪莉失踪时如此大声疾呼寻求答案，为什么在她安全返回后却保持沉默？难道这一切真的是人质谈判专家卡梅伦·甘布尔策划的宣传噱头吗？
Or perhaps Keith and Sherry had crafted the elaborate plot for financial gain and fame. Investigators had considered this possibility, but unless they had evidence to prove otherwise, they had no reason to treat the abduction as anything other than a legitimate crime. It was a lesson learned the hard way by Vallejo Police, just 180 miles south of Redding. The year before Sherry Papini's abduction, a Vallejo man named Aaron Quinn called police to report a home invasion. He claimed that a gunman had broken into his home and forced him and his girlfriend, Denise Hoskins, to drink tea laced with sleeping pills. They were blindfolded and tied up in the closet, where the gunman played a pre-recorded message. It explained that the couple had been targeted by a criminal group who were going to hold Denise captive, unless Aaron paid an $8,500 ransom within 48 hours. When Aaron woke up hours later, Denise was gone.
或者，也许是基思和雪莉为了经济利益和名声精心策划了这个复杂的阴谋。调查人员考虑过这种可能性，但除非有证据证明事实并非如此，否则他们没有理由将这起绑架案视为合法犯罪以外的事情。这是瓦列霍警方在雷丁以南仅180英里处学到的惨痛教训。在雪莉·帕皮尼被绑架的前一年，一名叫亚伦·奎因的瓦列霍男子报警称家中遭入室抢劫。他声称一名持枪歹徒闯入家中，强迫他和女友丹妮丝·霍斯金斯喝下掺有安眠药的茶。他们被蒙住双眼并绑在壁橱里，歹徒播放了一段预先录制的信息。信息解释说，这对夫妇被一个犯罪团伙盯上，如果亚伦不在48小时内支付8500美元赎金，他们就会扣押丹妮丝。当亚伦几小时后醒来时，丹妮丝已经不见了。
He reported the incident to police, but the story was so outlandish that they thought he was making it up. When Denise resurfaced two days later claiming to have been held captive and raped, both law enforcement and the media palmed it off as a wild hoax. Three months later, police were investigating an unrelated home invasion when they uncovered evidence linking the perpetrator to Denise Hoskins and Aaron Quinn. It turned out the couple had been telling the truth. The perpetrator, a disbarred attorney named Matthew Muller, was tried and sentenced to 31 years in prison. Vallejo police were forced to publicly apologize to Denise and Aaron, who were awarded a $2.5 million compensation payout. Investigators in the Sherry Papini case were determined not to make a similar mistake. Keith Papini released an exclusive statement to national news program Good Morning America to address the rumors surrounding his wife's case head-on.
他向警方报告了这起事件，但故事太离奇，警方认为他在编造。当丹妮丝两天后重新出现，声称自己被囚禁并遭到强奸时，执法部门和媒体都将其视为一场荒唐的骗局。三个月后，警方在调查一起无关的入室抢劫案时，发现了将肇事者与丹妮丝·霍斯金斯和亚伦·奎因联系起来的证据。事实证明，这对夫妇说的是真话。肇事者是一名被吊销执照的律师，名叫马修·穆勒，他被审判并判处31年监禁。瓦列霍警方被迫公开向丹妮丝和亚伦道歉，并向他们支付了250万美元的赔偿金。雪莉·帕皮尼案的调查人员决心不再犯同样的错误。基思·帕皮尼向全国新闻节目《早安美国》发表了一份独家声明，正面回应了围绕他妻子案件的传言。
He acknowledged the quote, double-edged sword that is social media. While modern technology had allowed news of Sherry's disappearance to spread quickly, those same people who helped spread the word now expected answers instantly and became angry when they didn't get the gory details. Keith said, Those people should be ashamed of their malicious subhuman behavior. We are not going to allow those people to take away our spirit, love or rejoice in our girl found alive and home where she belongs. I do not see a purpose in addressing each preposterous lie. Instead, may I give you a glimpse of the mixture of horror and elation that was my experience of reuniting with the love of my life and mother of our children. Keith went on to provide a harrowing account of Sherry's ordeal, complete with the details of her injuries, including the branding.
他承认了社交媒体这把“双刃剑”。虽然现代科技让雪莉失踪的消息迅速传播，但那些曾经帮助传播消息的人现在却期望立即得到答案，并在得不到血腥细节时感到愤怒。基思说：“那些人应该为他们这种恶毒的非人行为感到羞耻。我们不会允许这些人夺走我们的精神、爱，也不会允许他们对我们的女孩活着回来并回到她所属的家中感到幸灾乐祸。我不认为回应每一个荒谬的谎言有什么意义。相反，让我带你们一窥我与我一生的挚爱、我们孩子的母亲重逢时那种恐惧与狂喜交织的经历。”基思随后讲述了雪莉遭受的痛苦折磨，包括她受伤的细节，以及烙印的情况。
He remarked, Nothing could have prepared me for what I was about to see upon my arrival at the hospital, nor the details of the true hell I was about to hear. Acknowledging the tireless support of law enforcement and the public, Keith said, Thank you to the many incredible humans that have never known Sherry that facilitated in sharing our heartbreak across the globe. Sherry has always captured my heart, and it is no surprise that she has captured hearts not only through the country, but throughout the world. The following day, police held a press conference to acknowledge Sherry Papini's courage. They released brief details about her two captors and appealed for anyone with information to come forward. The fact that Sherry had overheard the perpetrators talking about a buyer and getting paid gave weight to the human trafficking theory.
他感叹道：“当我到达医院时，没有什么能让我为即将看到的一切做好准备，也没有什么能让我为即将听到的真实地狱般的细节做好准备。”在感谢执法部门和公众的不懈支持时，基思说：“感谢许多从未认识雪莉却帮助我们在全球范围内分享我们心碎经历的不可思议的人们。雪莉一直占据着我的心，她不仅俘获了全国人民的心，也俘获了全世界人民的心，这并不令人惊讶。”第二天，警方举行新闻发布会，表彰雪莉·帕皮尼的勇气。他们发布了关于两名绑架者的简要细节，并呼吁任何有信息的人挺身而出。雪莉无意中听到绑架者谈论买家和获得报酬的事实，为人口贩卖理论增加了分量。
Maybe the women had kidnapped Sherry at random, thinking she was much younger. When they realized she was a 34-year-old mother, they didn't know how to proceed, hence why they held her captive for so long and were constantly bickering. But if this was the case, it would be highly unusual. In the United States, white women are rarely abducted for sex trafficking. Victims usually know their exploiters, who are often tricked into willingly going with them after being promised a better life. Perpetrators involved are typically professionals. It would be highly unusual for someone involved in trafficking to let a victim go, as it risked exposing the entire ring. The fact that Sherry was branded also raised questions.
也许这两个女人是随机绑架了雪莉，以为她年轻得多。当她们意识到她是一位34岁的母亲时，她们不知道该如何处理，这就是为什么她们把她关押了这么久，而且一直在争吵。但如果真是这样，那将是非常罕见的。在美国，白人女性很少因性贩卖而被绑架。受害者通常认识剥削者，他们往往在被承诺更好的生活后被诱骗自愿跟随。涉及的肇事者通常是专业人士。对于参与贩卖的人来说，释放受害者是非常罕见的，因为这冒着暴露整个团伙的风险。雪莉被烙印的事实也引发了疑问。
Some believed this type of torture was typical for traffickers who wanted to maintain control over their victim, while others questioned why a sex trafficker would want to taint their own product. Based on the description that Sherry had provided of her time in captivity, investigators began working on the theory that she had been held somewhere in the mountains. They obtained cell phone data from the area where Sherry was abducted and the area where she was found, on the lookout for any numbers that pinged off phone towers at both locations. As reported by the Sacramento Bee, six numbers came up. Among them was a 21-year-old woman. Police visited her home, discovering that she had dark hair like Sherry's young captor, but she wasn't Latina and had an alibi for the abduction period. Tip-offs continued to come in from the public. One woman reported having seen a pair of Latina women who matched the suspect descriptions in a Walmart store.
有些人认为这种酷刑是那些想要维持对受害者控制的贩卖者的典型做法，而另一些人则质疑为什么性贩卖者会想要玷污自己的“产品”。根据雪莉提供的关于她被囚禁期间的描述，调查人员开始推测她被关在山里的某个地方。他们获取了雪莉被绑架区域和她被发现区域的手机数据，寻找在两个地点都连接过手机信号塔的任何号码。据《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》报道，出现了六个号码。其中一个是21岁的女性。警方走访了她的家，发现她有着像雪莉年轻绑架者那样的深色头发，但她不是拉丁裔，并且有绑架期间的不在场证明。公众提供的线索不断涌入。一名女子报告说在沃尔玛超市看到了一对符合嫌疑人描述的拉丁裔女性。
They were looking at her and whispering. The caller had blonde hair similar to Sherry Papini. She was scared that she might be next. By December 3, Sherry Papini had been home for a week and a half. Hundreds of redding locals gathered to celebrate her safe return and stand in solidarity with their community. Wearing pink in Sherry's honour, they posed for a photograph underneath a large pink banner that read, Welcome Home. Despite this warm response, Sherry struggled in the aftermath of her abduction. While her physical injuries eventually healed, the emotional scars remained.
她们看着她并窃窃私语。报警的女子有着和雪莉·帕皮尼相似的金发。她很害怕自己会是下一个。到12月3日，雪莉·帕皮尼已经回家一周半了。数百名雷丁当地人聚集在一起，庆祝她安全归来，并与他们的社区团结一致。他们穿着粉红色的衣服以纪念雪莉，并在一条写着“欢迎回家”的大型粉色横幅下合影留念。尽管有这种热烈的回应，雪莉在绑架事件后仍感到挣扎。虽然她的身体伤害最终愈合了，但情感创伤依然存在。
She became afraid of people, particularly strangers, and wanted Keith by her side at all times. Neighbours noted that she rarely left the house and her children hardly ever played out in the yard. Sherry began extensive therapy to treat post-traumatic stress disorder and anxiety. She met with investigators from time to time and officers checked in on the Papinis weekly. But Sherry's recollection of the events became hazy and she was unable to provide any new insights. The search for her abductors continued, but police failed to come up with any solid leads. A year went by with no major breakthroughs. To mark the upcoming anniversary, a police artist worked with Sherry to create composite sketches of her two captors,
她开始害怕人，尤其是陌生人，并希望基思时刻陪在她身边。邻居们注意到她很少出门，她的孩子们也几乎不在院子里玩耍。雪莉开始了广泛的治疗，以应对创伤后应激障碍和焦虑症。她不时与调查人员会面，警官每周都会查看帕皮尼一家的近况。但雪莉对事件的回忆变得模糊，她无法提供任何新的见解。对绑架者的搜寻仍在继续，但警方未能找到任何可靠的线索。一年过去了，没有取得任何重大突破。为了纪念即将到来的周年纪念日，一名警方的素描画家与雪莉合作，创作了两名绑架者的合成素描，
bandanas covering the bottom half of their faces. These were released to the public along with the first detailed account of Sherry's experience in captivity. Keith Papini released a statement on his family's behalf thanking their supporters and requesting privacy as his wife continued to heal and they focused on putting their lives back together. But for all the support, Sherry still had her fair share of critics. Following her safe return, an online blog post had surfaced from 2007 that had some people asking questions. The post had originally appeared on a white supremacy website called skinheads.com. It detailed the author's adolescent years during which her high school experience suffered because she was, quote,
头巾遮住了她们脸的下半部分。这些素描与雪莉被囚禁经历的首次详细描述一起向公众发布。基思·帕皮尼代表家人发表声明，感谢他们的支持者，并请求隐私，因为他的妻子仍在康复中，他们专注于重建生活。但尽管有所有的支持，雪莉仍然面临不少批评。在她安全返回后，2007年的一篇在线博客文章浮出水面，让一些人提出了质疑。这篇文章最初出现在一个名为skinheads.com的白人至上主义网站上。它详细描述了作者的青春期，当时她的高中经历很糟糕，因为她，引用：
defending myself against the Latinos. The chief problem was that I was drug free, white and proud of my blood and heritage. This really irked a group of Latino girls who would constantly rag and attack me. The author detailed an incident at one of her volleyball games. One of the Latina girls had apparently called her dad a Nazi which enraged the teen and provoked her to launch an attack. It took three full grown men to pull her off. By then she had broken the nose of one of her tormentors. The author used this event to explain why girls shouldn't fight stating,
“在为自己辩护，对抗拉丁裔。”主要问题是我不吸毒，是白人，并为我的血统和遗产感到自豪。这真的激怒了一群拉丁裔女孩，她们不断地嘲弄和攻击我。作者详细描述了她的一场排球比赛中发生的一起事件。其中一个拉丁裔女孩显然称她的父亲为纳粹，这激怒了这名少女，并促使她发动攻击。三个成年男子才把她拉开。那时她已经打断了其中一个折磨她的人的鼻子。作者用这件事来解释为什么女孩不应该打架，声称：
we are just too fragile and break easily. She spoke proudly of her German heritage concluding, being white is more than just being aware of my skin but of standing behind skinheads who are always around in spirit as well and having pride for my country. The author was credited as Sherry Graff. Sherry Papini's maiden name. An old account on social network site Pinterest also surfaced that was attributed to a user named Sherry Papini. The user had posted several images with pro-white and racist undertones. Sherry's critics immediately started speculating that she had made up the story of her kidnapping to ignite a race war. Latinos only made up 10% of Shasta County's population and since Sherry's kidnapping the minority group had faced ongoing scrutiny.
“我们太脆弱了，很容易受伤。”她自豪地谈到了她的德国血统，总结道：“身为白人不仅仅是意识到我的肤色，而是支持那些精神上始终存在的光头党，并为我的国家感到自豪。”作者署名为雪莉·格拉夫，即雪莉·帕皮尼的婚前姓氏。社交网站Pinterest上的一个旧账户也浮出水面，归属于一个名为雪莉·帕皮尼的用户。该用户发布了几张带有亲白人和种族主义色彩的图片。雪莉的批评者立即开始猜测她编造了绑架故事以引发种族战争。拉丁裔仅占沙斯塔县人口的10%，自雪莉被绑架以来，这个少数群体一直面临持续的审查。
According to the Sacramento Bee, local women of Latin American descent were advised not to go out in pairs, avoid driving dark colored SUVs and avoid going out in public unless they had a witness. Sherry's loved ones firmly denied the allegations that she had written the blog post. Sherry had been briefly married in 2007. Her ex-husband, with whom she had an amicable divorce, told reporters that Sherry wasn't racist and had a very diverse group of friends. He said the blog had been maliciously written by someone who hated Sherry in high school and that she had unsuccessfully attempted to have it removed at the time. When questioned by investigators, Sherry described the blog post as awful. She confirmed that she'd hired a lawyer to try and have it taken down.
据《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》报道，当地拉丁裔女性被建议不要结伴外出，避免驾驶深色SUV，除非有证人陪同，否则避免在公共场合露面。雪莉的亲人坚决否认了她写过那篇博客文章的指控。雪莉曾在2007年有过一段短暂的婚姻。她友善离婚的前夫告诉记者，雪莉并不种族主义，而且有一群非常多元化的朋友。他说这篇博客是高中时讨厌雪莉的人恶意撰写的，她当时曾试图删除但未成功。当被调查人员询问时，雪莉将这篇博客文章描述为“可怕的”。她证实她曾聘请律师试图将其删除。
Investigators looked into the claims that Sherry had written a post herself but were unable to ascertain its true origin. Regardless of who wrote it, they confirmed too much time had passed for it to be of any relevance to Sherry's current kidnapping case. Police openly acknowledged that there were puzzling details about Sherry's abduction but stated they had no reason to doubt Sherry's story. On the one year anniversary of the abduction, one of the lead investigators told People magazine, There is no information that would indicate it's not true. I have invested almost a year of my career in this case and we will continue on until we get some answers and hopefully get some people in custody soon. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support case file to continue to deliver quality content.
调查人员调查了雪莉自己写过这篇文章的说法，但无法确定其真实来源。无论谁写的，他们都确认时间已经过去太久，与雪莉目前的绑架案没有任何关联。警方公开承认，关于雪莉的绑架案有一些令人困惑的细节，但表示他们没有理由怀疑雪莉的故事。在绑架案一周年之际，其中一名首席调查员告诉《人物》杂志：“没有任何信息表明这不是真的。我在这个案件上投入了近一年的职业生涯，我们将继续努力，直到我们得到一些答案，并希望很快能将一些人拘留。”案件档案很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。
For investigators behind closed doors, unanswered questions were stacking up. For starters, a motive still hadn't been established. Sherry Papini's captors had never demanded a ransom and there was no conclusive evidence to support the human trafficking theory. So why had this unassuming mother been targeted? Her abductors were seemingly part of a wider network but there had been no other recent crimes that fit the same bill. It therefore seemed strange that they hadn't struck again elsewhere. Over time, other small inconsistencies had started to mount. Sherry had told investigators that she had cut her foot during an altercation with her younger captor.
对于闭门调查的调查人员来说，未解之谜正在堆积。首先，动机尚未确定。雪莉·帕皮尼的绑架者从未要求赎金，也没有确凿的证据支持人口贩卖理论。那么，这位谦逊的母亲为什么会被盯上？她的绑架者似乎是一个更广泛网络的一部分，但最近没有其他符合同样特征的犯罪。因此，他们没有在其他地方再次作案似乎很奇怪。随着时间的推移，其他一些小的不一致之处开始增加。雪莉曾告诉调查人员，她在与年轻绑架者的争执中割伤了脚。
Yet there had been no evidence of such a cut when she was first taken to hospital. She'd also given conflicting accounts of when the branding had happened. First saying it had happened early on and then changing her story and saying it happened later. Sherry had initially told investigators that she was forced to wear an adult diaper but never mentioned this detail again. Sherry said that when she first woke up in captivity, her hands had been tied behind her back with zip ties. She explained that she'd managed to chew through the bindings but had never explained how she managed to get her hands from behind her back. While investigators knew it was entirely possible that Sherry's memory had been distorted by trauma, the inconsistencies raised some major red flags.
然而，当她第一次被送往医院时，并没有这种伤口的证据。她还对烙印发生的时间给出了相互矛盾的说法。先是说发生在早期，后来又改口说发生在后期。雪莉最初告诉调查人员她被迫穿成人纸尿裤，但之后再也没有提到这个细节。雪莉说，当她第一次在囚禁中醒来时，她的双手被扎带绑在背后。她解释说她设法咬断了束缚，但从未解释她是如何设法把手从背后弄出来的。虽然调查人员知道雪莉的记忆完全可能因创伤而扭曲，但这些不一致之处引发了一些重大警示。
Perhaps most perplexing was the fact that when Sherry was found safe, her clothing was sent off for DNA testing. Traces of unknown male DNA was found on both her underwear and sweatpants but there was no female DNA. Investigators ran the profile through the National CODIS database in which DNA profiles from crime scenes and known offenders are stored. There were no matches. But if Sherry had been taken by two women with no one else involved, this didn't explain the DNA discrepancy. Investigators learned early on that Sherry had a history of lying. Several of Sherry's friends had described her as a crazy and wild youth who often ran away and made up stories, including that she suffered from a heart condition. An ex-boyfriend described her as a tension-hungry.
也许最令人困惑的是，当雪莉被安全发现时，她的衣服被送去进行DNA检测。在她的内衣和运动裤上都发现了不明男性DNA的痕迹，但没有女性DNA。调查人员将该档案通过国家CODIS数据库进行了比对，该数据库存储了来自犯罪现场和已知罪犯的DNA档案。没有匹配结果。但如果雪莉是被两个没有其他人参与的女性带走的，这并不能解释DNA的差异。调查人员很早就了解到雪莉有撒谎的历史。雪莉的几个朋友形容她是一个疯狂而狂野的年轻人，经常离家出走并编造故事，包括她患有心脏病。一位前男友形容她是一个“渴望关注的人”。
He said Sherry fabricated stories of being abused by her family and even accused him of abuse once their relationship ended. The director of a youth program that Sherry had once participated in said that Sherry was, quote, good at creating different realities for people so that they would see what she wanted them to see, which got her really good attention. Sherry's first marriage had been one of convenience. Her first husband was in the military and had agreed to marry Sherry so she could take advantage of his health insurance. While Sherry had told her second husband, Keith, this was due to a heart murmur, she had told her first husband it was due to complications from regular egg donation. Sherry had also told her first husband that her family was abusive. It was only after their divorce that mutual friends warned him that she had a history of lying.
他说雪莉编造了被家人虐待的故事，甚至在他们关系结束后指控他虐待。雪莉曾经参加过的一个青年项目的负责人说，雪莉“擅长为人们创造不同的现实，让他们看到她想让他们看到的东西，这让她得到了很好的关注”。雪莉的第一次婚姻是一场权宜之计。她的第一任丈夫在军队服役，并同意与雪莉结婚，这样她就可以利用他的健康保险。虽然雪莉告诉她的第二任丈夫基思这是因为心脏杂音，但她告诉她的第一任丈夫这是因为定期捐卵的并发症。雪莉还告诉她的第一任丈夫她的家人虐待她。直到他们离婚后，共同的朋友才警告他她有撒谎的历史。
Investigations conducted by the Sacramento B newspaper revealed that in 2003, Sherry's mother Loretta had called the local sheriff's department to lodge an incident report. Loretta claimed that her daughter was harming herself and then blaming the injuries on Loretta. A deputy had provided Loretta with advice but no further action was taken. This wasn't the only time a member of Sherry's family had reported her to the police. In 2000, Sherry's father Richard accused her of burglarizing his home. That same year, Sherry's sister Sheila had her back door vandalized. When she reported it to the police, she named Sherry as a suspect. Three years later, Richard alleged that Sherry stole money from his checking account.
《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》进行的调查显示，2003年，雪莉的母亲洛蕾塔曾致电当地治安官部门提交了一份事件报告。洛蕾塔声称她的女儿在伤害自己，然后将伤口归咎于洛蕾塔。一名副警长向洛蕾塔提供了建议，但没有采取进一步行动。这并不是雪莉的家人第一次向警方举报她。2000年，雪莉的父亲理查德指控她入室盗窃。同年，雪莉的姐姐希拉的后门遭到破坏。当她向警方报告时，她将雪莉列为嫌疑人。三年后，理查德声称雪莉从他的支票账户中偷了钱。
Although investigators had been aware of these issues, it didn't prove that Sherry was lying about her kidnapping. The hunt to find her abductors continued but the years passed by with no arrests. By 2020, the case had long faded from the headlines but it hadn't been forgotten by the Reading community who still wanted answers. Skepticism remained rife while fears that kidnappers were on the loose continued to haunt locals, some of whom had been too scared to let their young daughters walk alone ever since Sherry's attack. Sherry continued to work intermittently with the police. Whenever she remembered something new that could help with the investigation, she or her husband would call to make a report. Sherry looked online to find photos of anything that shared similarities to details from her abduction,
虽然调查人员已经意识到这些问题，但这并不能证明雪莉在绑架问题上撒谎。寻找绑架者的搜寻仍在继续，但几年过去了，没有任何逮捕行动。到2020年，该案件早已从头条新闻中淡出，但雷丁社区并没有忘记，他们仍然想要答案。怀疑论依然盛行，而绑架者逍遥法外的恐惧继续困扰着当地人，其中一些人自雪莉遇袭以来一直不敢让年幼的女儿独自走路。雪莉继续断断续续地与警方合作。每当她想起可能有助于调查的新情况时，她或她的丈夫就会打电话报告。雪莉在网上寻找任何与她绑架细节有相似之处的照片，
from the hairlines of her kidnappers, to the coffee table she was tied to during her branding. On August 13, 2020, Sherry and Keith Papini met with two detectives from the Shasta County Sheriff's Department who had been working the case from the beginning. They had some photos of potential suspects they wanted to show Sherry. She studied them carefully, looking at them from different angles and honing in on small features. I know. I would say right here is what's drawing me to this photo. So on photo number five, this is the first one we showed you, the second one we showed you. So on six-pack number two.
从绑架者的发际线，到她被烙印时被绑着的咖啡桌。2020年8月13日，雪莉和基思·帕皮尼会见了沙斯塔县治安官部门的两名侦探，他们从一开始就一直在处理此案。他们有一些潜在嫌疑人的照片想给雪莉看。她仔细研究了它们，从不同的角度观察，并专注于小的特征。“我知道。我会说就在这里，这吸引了我对这张照片的注意。所以照片五号，这是我们给您看的第一张，第二张我们给您看的。所以六张一组的第二组。”
But like you were saying, if someone were to lose weight, that would change. You're drawn to photo number five? Yes. Features of photo number five? Correct. And again, just for the record and for when you go back, number one is when you say three is similar. She's similar to the younger female that we've always described in everything. This part right here doesn't really match what I'm remembering.
“但就像你说的，如果有人减肥了，那就会改变。你被五号照片吸引了？”“是的。”“五号照片的特征？”“没错。再说一次，为了记录，也为了你回去的时候，一号是你说的三号相似。她和我们一直描述的年轻女性很像。这部分真的和我记忆中的不匹配。”
The hairline doesn't match? Smaller one, older one. Just because it's been a long time. Can you remind me what number, what the younger one did? Like the main parts of it compared to the older one just for the last like clarity and stuff. So for the record. The younger one is the one that let me go. And what's the nicer of the two?
“发际线不匹配？”“小的那个，年长的那个。只是因为已经过去很久了。你能提醒我一下，那个年轻的做了什么吗？比如和年长的相比的主要部分，为了最后的清晰度之类的。为了记录。”“年轻的是放我走的那个。两个中比较好的那个？”
The older one was really abusive and really mean and is the one that did all the really terrible things. The detectives then showed Sherry some photos of coffee tables similar to the ones she had described. Focusing on one of them, Sherry enthusiastically exclaimed, excuse my language, but it's pretty fucking similar. I mean, this is what I'm remembering that feeling, you know, grabbing it and feeling that feeling. But this part is different. This part is different. That doesn't definitely. So you're saying this metal part looks the same as what you remember. But this piece right here.
“年长的那个真的很虐待人，真的很刻薄，是做所有那些非常可怕的事情的人。”侦探们随后给雪莉看了一些类似于她描述的咖啡桌的照片。雪莉盯着其中一张，热情地惊呼道：“原谅我的语言，但这他妈的太像了。我的意思是，这就是我记忆中的那种感觉，你知道，抓住它，感觉到那种感觉。但这部分不同。这部分不同。那绝对不是。所以你是说这个金属部分看起来和你记得的一样。但这块就在这里。”
This part doesn't look the same, right? And what was the difference in it? That there was a lot more. There was a lot more there. Like bulkier? Thank you. I don't think the picture really showed. Sherry had always described her captor's bathroom as having a unique layout.
“这部分看起来不一样，对吧？它有什么不同？”“那里多了很多。那里多了很多。比如更笨重？”“谢谢。我不认为照片真的显示出来了。”雪莉一直描述她绑架者的浴室布局独特。
The detectives showed her some photos of bathrooms with similar designs to the one she'd described. Sherry acknowledged the layouts were similar, but that was all. She'd previously said there was a crack in the shower tile. Shown a photo of a shower with a crack in it, Sherry couldn't say whether it was the same one. After all these years, she was struggling to remember. The detectives made it clear they weren't trying to overwhelm Sherry. There was actually a good reason for the probing. They had found the house that Sherry was held in, and they knew who was responsible.
侦探们给她看了一些设计与她描述的相似的浴室照片。雪莉承认布局相似，但仅此而已。她之前说过淋浴瓷砖上有裂缝。当看到一张有裂缝的淋浴照片时，雪莉无法说出那是否是同一个。毕竟这么多年了，她很难记起来。侦探们明确表示他们并没有试图让雪莉不知所措。其实这种盘问有一个很好的理由。他们已经找到了关押雪莉的房子，并且知道是谁负责的。
Keith Papini was elated. He pumped his fists in the air and rubbed his hands together in glee. But Sherry's reaction was surprising. She became strangely defensive. Over the years, investigators had continued to run checks on the DNA found on Sherry's clothing in case someone new had entered the CODIS database during that time. No matches were ever made. Then came the rise of genealogy testing, where users voluntarily submitted DNA to trace their family trees.
基思·帕皮尼欣喜若狂。他兴奋地挥舞着拳头，双手搓在一起。但雪莉的反应令人惊讶。她变得异常防御。多年来，调查人员一直在对雪莉衣服上发现的DNA进行检查，以防在此期间有人进入CODIS数据库。从未有匹配结果。然后是基因检测的兴起，用户自愿提交DNA来追踪他们的家谱。
In 2018, familial DNA had led to the apprehension of the notorious Golden State Killer, as covered in episode 53 of Case File. Investigators wondered whether the same technique could be applied to identify Sherry Papini's captors. In March 2020, they ran the DNA from Sherry's clothing through an ancestry DNA database. This time, there was a match. The DNA in the database belonged to an individual who had two biological sons. One of those was James Reyes, a man in his mid-30s who lived in the Californian city of Costa Mesa, 585 miles south of Reading.
2018年，家族DNA导致了臭名昭著的“金州杀手”的被捕，正如Casefile第53集所报道的那样。调查人员想知道是否可以使用相同的技术来识别雪莉·帕皮尼的绑架者。2020年3月，他们将雪莉衣服上的DNA通过祖源DNA数据库进行了比对。这一次，有了匹配结果。数据库中的DNA属于一个有两个亲生儿子的个人。其中一个是詹姆斯·雷耶斯，一个30多岁的男子，住在加利福尼亚州的科斯塔梅萨市，位于雷丁以南585英里处。
Reyes appeared to be a law-abiding citizen. A check of his background revealed no major criminal record, save for a drunk driving charge. But, as police dug further, they discovered some interesting details. James Reyes had once shared an email account with Sherry Papini. In the past, the two had made joint financial transactions. Furthermore, Reyes had once listed his address as a residence owned by Sherry's parents. Investigators searched through social media. The account owned by James Reyes's brother, they found a picture of a coffee table that looked exactly like the one Sherry had described being tied to while she was branded.
雷耶斯看起来是一个守法的公民。对他背景的调查显示没有重大犯罪记录，除了酒后驾驶指控。但是，随着警方深入挖掘，他们发现了一些有趣的细节。詹姆斯·雷耶斯曾经与雪莉·帕皮尼共用一个电子邮件账户。过去，两人曾进行过联合金融交易。此外，雷耶斯曾将他的地址列为雪莉父母拥有的住所。调查人员搜索了社交媒体。在詹姆斯·雷耶斯兄弟拥有的账户中，他们发现了一张咖啡桌的照片，看起来和雪莉描述她在被烙印时被绑在上面的那张一模一样。
They went to Costa Mesa and kept a covert eye on Reyes's property. After seeing him discard some trash, they retrieved a bottle of iced tea and sent it to the lab for testing. There was no doubt about it. The DNA on Sherry Papini's clothing had come from James Reyes. Two detectives knocked on Reyes's door and asked him a few questions about himself and his relationship with Sherry Papini. A former professional hockey player, Reyes had recently quit his job at an ice skating rink to take care of his aging grandmother. He met Sherry through a youth group as a teenager. In late 2002, the two reconnected and started dating.
他们去了科斯塔梅萨，暗中监视雷耶斯的房产。在看到他丢弃一些垃圾后，他们取回了一瓶冰茶并送往实验室进行检测。毫无疑问。雪莉·帕皮尼衣服上的DNA来自詹姆斯·雷耶斯。两名侦探敲了雷耶斯的门，问了他一些关于他自己以及他与雪莉·帕皮尼关系的问题。作为一名前职业曲棍球运动员，雷耶斯最近辞去了溜冰场的工作，以照顾他年迈的祖母。他在青少年时期通过一个青年团体认识了雪莉。2002年底，两人重新联系并开始约会。
They were together for several years and lived together in Costa Mesa, but the relationship eventually crumbled. They ended things on good terms and stayed in vague contact for a few years, but Reyes said he hadn't seen Sherry in around a decade. All he knew about her abduction was whatever was reported on in the media. The detectives cut to the chase. They told Reyes his DNA had been found on Sherry's clothing the day she escaped her captors. Reyes seemed perplexed. He maintained the two hadn't seen one another since around mid-2006. He had no explanation for how his DNA could have gotten on Sherry's clothes.
他们在一起几年，并住在科斯塔梅萨，但这段关系最终破裂了。他们以友好的方式结束了关系，并保持了几年模糊的联系，但雷耶斯说他已经大约十年没见过雪莉了。关于她的绑架，他所知道的只是媒体报道的内容。侦探们直奔主题。他们告诉雷耶斯，在她逃离绑架者的那天，在雪莉的衣服上发现了他的DNA。雷耶斯显得很困惑。他坚持认为两人自2006年中期左右就没见过面。他无法解释他的DNA是如何出现在雪莉衣服上的。
Asked point blank if he was involved in Sherry's abduction, Reyes said no. The investigators reiterated that there was no way his DNA could have gotten on her clothing if they hadn't been in contact. They gave him several opportunities to change his story, reminding him it was a crime to lie to law enforcement. But Reyes maintained he had nothing to do with the abduction. After almost an hour of questioning, Reyes cracked. I didn't kidnap her, he said. A friend in need asked me for help. According to James Reyes, he was cleaning out his house in 2015 when he came across some of Sherry's old belongings.
当被直接问及他是否参与了雪莉的绑架时，雷耶斯说没有。调查人员重申，如果他们没有接触过，他的DNA不可能出现在她的衣服上。他们给了他几次改变故事的机会，提醒他向执法部门撒谎是犯罪。但雷耶斯坚持说他与绑架无关。经过近一个小时的盘问，雷耶斯崩溃了。“我没有绑架她，”他说。“一个有需要的朋友向我寻求帮助。”据詹姆斯·雷耶斯说，他在2015年清理房子时，偶然发现了雪莉的一些旧物。
He sent them to her parents' house. Not long after that, Sherry contacted him out of the blue. She needed his help. She said her husband had been beating and raping her and she didn't know what to do. She'd reported the abuse to police but her husband had connections with law enforcement and nothing had been done. At a loss, Sherry told Reyes she'd hatched a plan. She was saving money and was going to run away to stay with him. Reyes was taken aback but more than willing to help a friend in need.
他把它们寄到了她父母家。没过多久，雪莉就突然联系了他。她需要他的帮助。她说她的丈夫一直在殴打和强奸她，她不知道该怎么办。她向警方报告了虐待行为，但她的丈夫与执法部门有关系，什么也没做。走投无路之下，雪莉告诉雷耶斯她制定了一个计划。她正在存钱，打算逃跑去和他住在一起。雷耶斯大吃一惊，但非常愿意帮助有需要的朋友。
Sherry asked him to get a prepaid burner phone so they could speak without fear of her husband finding out. The two maintained regular contact from that point on. In the summer of 2016, Sherry gave Reyes a set of instructions. Rent a car and to drive to Reading to pick her up. Tell no one. James Reyes's drink driving charge prohibited him from renting a car. Instead, he organised a co-worker to hire one for him. It was a Dodge Challenger sports car, not an SUV as Sherry had described her kidnappers as using.
雪莉让他买一部预付费的“一次性手机”，这样他们就可以在不用担心被她丈夫发现的情况下交谈。从那时起，两人保持着经常联系。2016年夏天，雪莉给了雷耶斯一系列指示。租一辆车，开车去雷丁接她。不要告诉任何人。詹姆斯·雷耶斯的酒驾指控禁止他租车。相反，他组织了一位同事为他租了一辆。那是一辆道奇挑战者跑车，而不是雪莉描述绑架者使用的SUV。
On November 2, 2016, Reyes set out on the 9-hour drive. When he got to Reading, Sherry texted the directions on where to pick her up near Old Oregon Trail. When Reyes got there, Sherry was wearing jogging clothes and sweating. She jumped into the back seat and laid low. Reyes didn't see what she did with her phone. The two drove back to Costa Mesa rarely stopping except for gas. Sherry laid down and napped for the entire journey while Reyes struggled to keep his eyes open after so many hours behind the wheel. Reyes lived in a suburban neighbourhood in Costa Mesa.
2016年11月2日，雷耶斯开始了9小时的车程。当他到达雷丁时，雪莉发短信告知在旧俄勒冈小径附近接她的方向。当雷耶斯到达那里时，雪莉穿着慢跑服，满头大汗。她跳进后座，低着头。雷耶斯没看到她怎么处理她的手机。两人开车回科斯塔梅萨，除了加油几乎没停过。雪莉在整个旅程中躺下打盹，而雷耶斯在开车这么多小时后努力保持清醒。雷耶斯住在科斯塔梅萨的一个郊区社区。
Once they were at Reyes's apartment, he claimed they both did their own thing. Reyes went about his normal routine, going to work each day and sometimes playing hockey at night. He slept on the couch while Sherry took his bedroom. He left Sherry to her own devices, assuming she was doing whatever she felt necessary to deal with her situation. Reyes claimed he had no input in any of Sherry's plans. He simply went along with whatever she told him to do. He bought her new clothes, cleaning supplies, food and chains. He bought it up the window.
一旦他们到了雷耶斯的公寓，他声称他们都各做各的事。雷耶斯照常生活，每天去上班，有时晚上打曲棍球。他睡在沙发上，而雪莉占用了他的卧室。他让雪莉自己处理，假设她在做她认为处理自己情况所必需的任何事情。雷耶斯声称他没有参与雪莉的任何计划。他只是顺从她告诉他做的任何事情。他给她买了新衣服、清洁用品、食物和链子。他把窗户封上了。
At no point did Sherry leave the house, nor did anyone else come over. Reyes did confide in his cousin that Sherry was there, explaining that he was helping protect her. But all this didn't explain Sherry's extensive injuries. When asked about those, Reyes responded. She did all that while she was here. Reyes claimed that Sherry hid herself to create bruises and that at her request, he agreed to help. While he never outright touched Sherry, Reyes admitted to hitting hockey pucks at her. At one point, he held up a hockey stick so that Sherry could purposely run into it, breaking her nose in the process.
雪莉从未离开过房子，也没有其他人来过。雷耶斯确实向他的表弟吐露了雪莉在那里，解释说他是在帮助保护她。但这一切并不能解释雪莉的大量伤口。当被问及这些时，雷耶斯回答：“她在这里时自己做了这一切。”雷耶斯声称雪莉把自己藏起来制造淤青，并且应她的要求，他同意帮忙。虽然他从未直接触碰雪莉，但雷耶斯承认向她投掷曲棍球。有一次，他举起一根曲棍球杆，让雪莉可以故意撞上去，在此过程中打断了她的鼻子。
Sherry cut her own hair and limited her food intake. She told Reyes to visit the local hobby store and purchase a wood burning tool. She willingly removed her shirt and sat down with her back to Reyes, handing him individual letters that she wanted burned into her skin. He didn't know what the word meant or why she had chosen it. All he knew was that it was a Bible verse. Reyes didn't own a TV, so he didn't know the full extent of the media coverage Sherry's disappearance was receiving. The detectives asked if he kept any kind of insurance, something that would prove his story if Sherry had been found in his home and denied that it was all consensual. Reyes said he hadn't felt the need to.
雪莉剪掉了自己的头发，并限制了食物摄入。她告诉雷耶斯去当地的工艺品店买一个木刻工具。她自愿脱掉衬衫，背对着雷耶斯坐下，递给他她想烧在皮肤上的单个字母。他不知道这个词是什么意思，也不知道她为什么选择它。他只知道这是一句圣经经文。雷耶斯没有电视，所以他不知道雪莉失踪所受到的媒体报道的全部程度。侦探们问他是否保留了任何形式的保险，如果雪莉在他家中被发现并否认这一切是自愿的，这将证明他的故事。雷耶斯说他觉得没必要。
While he didn't know what Sherry's intentions were for when the whole situation was over, he thought there was a chance they might end up together in the end. This wasn't a motivator to Reyes either way, as he wasn't really in a place to start a romantic relationship. Regardless, Reyes said that nothing remotely sexual occurred between the two. Eventually, Sherry said she missed her children and wanted to go home. Reyes had his co-worker hire him another car. In the early hours of Thanksgiving morning, Sherry gathered up a pillowcase of items, including chains. The pair drove to Yolo County, where Reyes dropped Sherry off on the side of the road. From there, he returned home to retrieve his car, then continued to his aunt's house for Thanksgiving lunch.
虽然他不知道雪莉在整个情况结束后有什么打算，但他认为他们最终可能会在一起。这对雷耶斯来说也不是动机，因为他并没有处于开始浪漫关系的阶段。无论如何，雷耶斯说两人之间没有发生任何性行为。最终，雪莉说她想念她的孩子，想回家。雷耶斯让他的同事又为他租了一辆车。在感恩节早晨的凌晨，雪莉收拾了一个装有物品的枕套，包括链子。两人开车前往约洛县，雷耶斯把雪莉放在路边。从那里，他回家取回他的车，然后继续前往他阿姨家吃感恩节午餐。
He hadn't spoken to Sherry since. Reyes admitted he'd looked Sherry's case up from time to time. He didn't know what possessed her to blame the abduction on two fictional Hispanic women. He had considered whether he'd get in trouble, but justified his involvement to the detectives. Quote, When it comes down to it, I was doing an old friend a favor. When investigators saw James Reyes' bedroom, it was exactly as Sherry had described. The only difference was that there was no chain in the closet.
从那以后他再没和雪莉说过话。雷耶斯承认他时不时会查一下雪莉的案子。他不知道是什么让她把绑架归咎于两个虚构的西班牙裔女性。他曾考虑过自己是否会惹上麻烦，但向侦探们证明了自己的参与。“归根结底，”他说，“我是在帮一位老朋友的忙。”当调查人员看到詹姆斯·雷耶斯的卧室时，它和雪莉描述的一模一样。唯一的区别是衣柜里没有链子。
They questioned Reyes' cousin and his wife, who confirmed that Sherry had willingly stayed with Reyes during her so-called timing captivity. Blonde hairs found in his bedroom were tested for DNA and confirmed to have come from Sherry Papini. Other data, including car rental records and cell phone data, also confirmed to James Reyes' version of events. He agreed to a polygraph test and passed. Friends of Reyes told detectives that he was the nicest guy alive, to a fault. Armed with this information, the detectives repeatedly reminded Sherry who was a crime to lie to federal agents. When they told her they'd identified the house where she'd been held captive, she was visibly caught off guard. She seemed reluctant to receive the information, which confused her husband Keith.
他们审问了雷耶斯的表弟和他的妻子，他们证实雪莉在所谓的囚禁期间自愿和雷耶斯住在一起。在他卧室里发现的金发被送去进行DNA检测，证实来自雪莉·帕皮尼。其他数据，包括租车记录和手机数据，也证实了詹姆斯·雷耶斯的事件版本。他同意进行测谎仪测试并顺利通过。雷耶斯的朋友告诉侦探，他是世界上最好的人，甚至好到过头了。掌握了这些信息后，侦探们反复提醒雪莉向联邦特工撒谎是犯罪。当他们告诉她他们已经确定了她被关押的房子时，她明显感到措手不及。她似乎不愿接受这些信息，这让她的丈夫基思感到困惑。
The detectives told Sherry they'd found DNA and uncovered several inconsistencies in her story. Still, Sherry seemed perplexed. She asked to have a moment alone to speak to her husband. Alone, Sherry and Keith began speaking in whispers. Sherry explained the reason she is hesitant to have her captor's identity revealed was because she didn't want the younger woman to be arrested. When the detectives came back into the room, Sherry admitted that she didn't want the younger of her captors to be punished. It was clear that she wasn't going to budge from her version of events. Detectives gave it to her straight, saying,
侦探们告诉雪莉，他们已经发现了DNA，并揭露了她故事中的几处矛盾。然而，雪莉似乎感到困惑。她要求单独和丈夫谈谈。独处时，雪莉和基思开始低声交谈。雪莉解释说，她之所以不愿透露绑架者的身份，是因为她不想让那个年轻女子被捕。当侦探们回到房间时，雪莉承认她不想让绑架者中较年轻的那位受到惩罚。很明显，她不打算改变自己的说法。侦探们直截了当地告诉她：
The DNA that was on you belongs to James Reyes. In this situation, the reason why you can describe the room is because you stayed in the room in the dark for hours, for days on end. The reason why you lost so much weight is because you stopped eating. The reason why you got a rash on your arm is because you cleaned his house. The reason why the brand is because he went to the store and bought the brandy tools and branded you. The reason why your nose was broke is because of a hockey stick. I know all of those things, and I know there was no sex. I know all of that because he passed a polygraph test.
你身上的DNA属于詹姆斯·雷耶斯。在这种情况下，你能描述那个房间的原因是因为你在黑暗中待了几个小时，甚至几天。你体重减轻的原因是因为你停止了进食。你手臂上出现皮疹的原因是因为你打扫了他的房子。之所以有烙印，是因为他去商店买了烙印工具并给你烙了印。你的鼻子骨折是因为曲棍球棒。我知道所有这些事情，而且我知道并没有发生性行为。我知道这一切，因为他通过了测谎仪测试。
That said, it's not an abduction. She asked me to come together. No. I rented a car. No. I drove up and picked her up. He passed the polygraph test, Sherry. If that's not what happened, what did happen, Sherry?
话虽如此，这不是绑架。她让我一起去。不。我租了一辆车。不。我开车去接她。他通过了测谎仪测试，雪莉。如果事情不是这样发生的，那到底发生了什么，雪莉？
I don't know. No, there's no way it's James. There's no way. There's no way. The DNA doesn't lie. His DNA. His DNA was on you. There's no way.
我不知道。不，不可能是詹姆斯。不可能。不可能。DNA不会撒谎。他的DNA。他的DNA在你身上。不可能。
Robert saw you in the house while you were down there. While everything spun out of control, his cousin. Why everything ran out of control on the initial. There's no way. It's 100% Robert's DNA. You even collected blonde hairs from the room. There's no way it's James. There's no way.
罗伯特在你待在那里的时候在房子里见过你。当一切失控时，他的表弟。为什么最初的一切都失控了。不可能。这百分之百是罗伯特的DNA。你甚至从房间里收集了金色的头发。不可能是詹姆斯。不可能。
Why are you saying it's not James? Why are you saying there's no? He approached me. What's up? We were friends. There's no way. And he came and got you because you asked him? No.
你为什么说不是詹姆斯？你为什么说没有？他接近我。怎么了？我们是朋友。不可能。他来接你是你要求的吗？不。
When was the last time you had contact with James? Sherry sat with her head in her hands sobbing. Confronted with the truth about how she received her injuries, she acted confused. She said she hadn't seen James Reyes in over 10 years. Confronted again and again with evidence, Sherry continued to play dumb. The detectives asked Keith to leave the room. Alone with Sherry, they asked her whether she was trying to escape an abusive marriage or teach Keith a lesson. Sherry sobbed even harder.
你最后一次和詹姆斯联系是什么时候？雪莉双手抱头，啜泣着。面对她受伤真相的质问，她表现得很困惑。她说她已经十多年没见过詹姆斯·雷耶斯了。面对一次又一次的证据，雪莉继续装傻。侦探们让基思离开房间。在与雪莉独处时，他们问她是否想逃离一段虐待性的婚姻，或者想给基思一个教训。雪莉哭得更厉害了。
She tearfully admitted to speaking with other men when she shouldn't have. Why would I do that? She sobbed almost incoherently. I don't want to leave my husband. I love my husband. The detectives made it very clear that James Reyes had confessed to his part in the whole ordeal. They gave Sherry numerous opportunities to come clean, letting her know they couldn't help her if she continued to lie. Nobody else.
她含泪承认自己曾与不该联系的其他男人交谈。我为什么要那样做？她啜泣着，几乎语无伦次。我不想离开我的丈夫。我爱我的丈夫。侦探们非常明确地表示，詹姆斯·雷耶斯已经承认了他在整个事件中的角色。他们给了雪莉多次坦白的机会，让她知道如果她继续撒谎，他们就无法帮助她。没有别人。
He got nothing out of this. And you're welcome to go home, Sherry. But right now is your opportunity to help the truth. And... Keith... Are you saying that it was two females that picked you up? What's that? Every time I ask that question, it seems like you don't answer it.
他从这件事中什么也没得到。雪莉，你可以回家了。但现在是你帮助还原真相的机会。而且……基思……你是说有两个女性接走了你吗？什么？每次我问这个问题，你似乎都不回答。
I can't even... You sounded rude. You drew out two people in a sketch, Sherry. Or it was two people, the ones that took you. It's a yes or no. I don't know. Well, you were pretty clear when I asked you earlier, what did the younger one do? You said the younger one pointed a gun at you.
我甚至不能……你听起来很粗鲁。雪莉，你在素描中画出了两个人。或者确实是两个人，带走你的那些人。这是一个是或否的问题。我不知道。好吧，我之前问你的时候你很清楚，那个年轻的做了什么？你说那个年轻的用枪指着你。
She was staring at me. She wasn't. It was just James. James was two hours late. We have the rental records from 2016 for the vehicle that you used. Why? Because we wouldn't look for it because he told me... Because I was talking to him.
她盯着我看。她没有。只有詹姆斯。詹姆斯迟到了两个小时。我们有你使用的车辆2016年的租赁记录。为什么？因为我们不会去寻找它，因为他告诉我……因为我在和他说话。
That's clear. You were talking to him. I don't... It was my fault because I was talking to him. I just can't. We have to control what we can control. No. We're to the point that the younger female that you've always described,
这很清楚。你在和他说话。我不……是我的错，因为我在和他说话。我只是不能。我们必须控制我们能控制的事情。不。我们已经到了你一直描述的那个年轻女性的地步，
is she the one that put a gun at you? Is that true or not? No. You do know. You told me earlier. So earlier today, when we were talking, I asked you what did the younger one do? You told me the younger one pointed a gun at you.
是她用枪指着你吗？这是真的还是假的？不。你知道的。你之前告诉过我。所以今天早些时候，当我们交谈时，我问你那个年轻的做了什么？你告诉我那个年轻的用枪指着你。
And let you go. That's what you said. She let me go. You let yourself go. You let yourself out of the back seat. Never even said bye to James. Never thanked you, never enough just to now. No.
然后放了你。你是这么说的。她放了我。你自己放了自己。你自己从后座出来的。从来没跟詹姆斯说再见。从来没感谢过，从来没有足够……不。
Yeah, that's what James told me. Until you can start telling me that James is a liar and start pointing things out, James passed a polygraph. This is my fault. My fault that I was talking to him. My fault that I was flirting with other men. It was such a stupid thing to do. I love my husband.
是的，詹姆斯就是这么告诉我的。除非你能开始告诉我詹姆斯是个骗子并开始指出问题，否则詹姆斯通过了测谎仪。这是我的错。我跟他说话是我的错。我和其他男人调情是我的错。这真是太愚蠢了。我爱我的丈夫。
I love my children. That's understandable. It's just stupid. Here's the deal though, Sherry. Flirting with other men? Not a crime. Lying to me today? Yes, a crime.
我爱我的孩子们。这可以理解。这只是愚蠢。不过，雪莉，交易是这样的。和别的男人调情？不是犯罪。今天对我撒谎？是的，是犯罪。
When asked if a female pointed a gun at her, Sherry said she couldn't remember. She said she refused to get anyone in trouble, crying, I know you know who she is. The detectives told Sherry that at this point, the only person who was going to get in trouble was her. Sherry responded tearfully,
当被问及是否有女性用枪指着她时，雪莉说她记不清了。她说她拒绝让任何人惹上麻烦，哭着说，我知道你知道她是谁。侦探们告诉雪莉，此时此刻，唯一会惹上麻烦的人就是她自己。雪莉含泪回应，
I didn't do anything wrong. I don't understand. There's no way that it's James. With no admission, Sherry was free to go home. Investigators continued building their case against her for a year and a half. It was determined that all up law enforcement spent more than $150,000 in resources
我没做错任何事。我不明白。不可能是詹姆斯。由于没有认罪，雪莉可以自由回家。调查人员继续为她建立案件长达一年半。据确定，所有执法部门在调查雪莉所谓的绑架案上花费了超过15万美元的资源。
investigating Sherry's so-called abduction. Concerned community members who rallied behind the Papinis had raised $49,000 in a GoFundMe account. The Papinis used this money to fund a private investigator, pay off credit card debt and other personal expenses. In total, Sherry had received a little over $30,500 from the California Victim Compensation Board, which had been spent on therapy, ambulances
关心此事的社区成员支持帕皮尼一家，并在GoFundMe账户上筹集了49,000美元。帕皮尼一家用这笔钱资助了一名私家侦探，偿还信用卡债务和其他个人开支。总共，雪莉从加州受害者赔偿委员会获得了略多于30,500美元，这些钱用于治疗、救护车
and blackout blinds. She also received $127,000 in disability benefits. By early March 2020, over five years had passed since Sherry Papini went through with the hoax. She was attending a piano lesson with her two children when a man burst in and said her car outside had been hit. It was all a lure by detectives. As soon as Sherry walked out, she was placed under arrest.
和遮光窗帘。她还获得了127,000美元的残疾福利。到2020年3月初，雪莉·帕皮尼实施这场骗局已经过去了五年多。她当时正带着两个孩子上钢琴课，一名男子冲进来，说她停在外面的车被撞了。这全是侦探们设下的诱饵。雪莉一走出来，就被逮捕了。
Given that she'd received some of the compensation payments via U.S. Postal Service, she was charged with mail fraud as well as making false statements. A spokesperson for the Shasta County Sheriff's Department made a post on Facebook that read, Today is a great day for the Shasta County Sheriff's Office and for all law enforcement in this county. Not only did this charade take valuable resources away
鉴于她通过美国邮政服务收到了一些赔偿金，她被指控犯有邮件欺诈罪以及作虚假陈述罪。沙斯塔县治安官办公室的一位发言人在Facebook上发帖称，今天是沙斯塔县治安官办公室和本县所有执法部门美好的一天。这场闹剧不仅占用了宝贵的资源，
from real criminal investigative matters, but in a time where there are serious human trafficking cases with legitimate victims, Sherry Papini used this tragic societal phenomenon to gain notoriety and financial gain. James Reyes was never charged for his involvement in the so-called abduction. If found guilty, Sherry Papini faced a possible 25 years in prison.
使其无法处理真正的刑事调查事项，而且在存在严重的涉及合法受害者的人口贩运案件时，雪莉·帕皮尼利用这种悲惨的社会现象来博取名声和经济利益。詹姆斯·雷耶斯从未因参与所谓的绑架案而被起诉。如果罪名成立，雪莉·帕皮尼可能面临25年监禁。
In mid-April, she pleaded guilty to the charges in the hopes of receiving a lesser sentence. Her defense team blamed Sherry's actions on a painful upbringing and, quote, chameleonic personalities, which they said drove her to simultaneously crave family security and the freedom of youth. They said she inflicted the injuries on herself as penance and her lies spiralled out of control
4月中旬，她对指控表示认罪，希望能获得较轻的判决。她的辩护团队将雪莉的行为归咎于痛苦的成长经历和所谓的“变色龙人格”，称这促使她同时渴望家庭安全和青春的自由。他们说她为了赎罪而自残，当她意识到自己所做的一切时，谎言就失控了。
when she realized what she'd done. The defense argued for one month in prison followed by seven months of home detention, stating, It is hard to imagine a more brutal public revelation of a person's broken inner self. At this point, the punishment is already intense and feels like a life sentence. The prosecution debated this, stating,
辩方主张判处一个月监禁，随后进行七个月的居家监禁，并表示：“很难想象还有比这更残酷的个人破碎内心的公开揭露。在这一点上，惩罚已经很强烈，感觉就像终身监禁。”检方对此进行了辩论，称，
Papini's planning of her hoax kidnapping was meticulous and began months in advance. It was not merely the reaction to a traumatic childhood. They said it was important to acknowledge that, quote, an entire community believed the hoax and lived in fear that Hispanic women were roving the streets to abduct and sell women. Ultimately, Sherry Papini was sentenced to 18 months in prison
帕皮尼策划她的绑架骗局非常细致，并提前几个月就开始了。这不仅仅是对童年创伤的反应。他们说，重要的是要承认，“整个社区都相信了这个骗局，并生活在恐惧中，担心西班牙裔女性在街上游荡，绑架和贩卖妇女。”最终，雪莉·帕皮尼被判处18个月监禁，
and ordered to pay restitution of just over $300,000. She admitted to the lies and offered no explanation for her actions, telling the judge, Keith Papini had always stood by Sherry's side. His unfaltering loyalty had seen him and his children be the victims of hate mail and threats. But as soon as the truth about Sherry's part and the kidnapping hoax came to light, Keith filed for divorce.
并被勒令支付超过30万美元的赔偿金。她承认了谎言，但没有对自己的行为做出任何解释，她告诉法官，基思·帕皮尼一直站在雪莉身边。他坚定不移的忠诚使他和他的孩子们成为了仇恨邮件和威胁的受害者。但当雪莉在绑架骗局中的角色真相大白后，基思立即提出了离婚。
He applied for full custody of the children, releasing one final public statement that said, The events of the past two months have been shocking and devastating. My current focus is on moving on and doing everything I can to provide my two children with as normal, healthy, and happy of a life as possible. Sherry didn't admit the truth about her lies to her family until the day before she pleaded guilty in court.
他申请了孩子的完全监护权，并发表了最后一份公开声明，称：“过去两个月的事件令人震惊和悲痛。我目前的重点是继续前进，尽我所能为我的两个孩子提供尽可能正常、健康和幸福的生活。”直到认罪的前一天，雪莉才向家人承认了谎言的真相。
In a Facebook post following Sherry's sentencing, her sister Sheila wrote, That Sherry could intentionally mislead her own beautiful children, her devoted husband Keith, our families, the authorities, and all of you for so long is beyond comprehension and was done for reasons for which only she is aware. Sadly, despite what she has expressed to the media, she feels no remorse or guilt for the untold damage she has caused,
在雪莉被判刑后的Facebook帖子中，她的妹妹希拉写道：“雪莉竟然能如此长时间地蓄意误导她自己美丽的儿女、她忠诚的丈夫基思、我们的家人、当局以及你们所有人，这简直令人无法理解，而且其原因只有她自己知道。可悲的是，尽管她向媒体表达了什么，但她对自己造成的无法估量的伤害毫无悔意或愧疚，
nor for taking advantage of critical criminal, financial and mental health resources that should have gone to help real victims in need. It deeply pains me to say this, but my sister is very disturbed, and I hope for her children's sake, once she is released, she will finally get the treatment she clearly so desperately needs. To this day, no one knows for sure
也没有为占用本应帮助真正受害者的关键刑事、经济和心理健康资源而感到愧疚。说出这些让我深感痛苦，但我姐姐病得很重，我希望为了她孩子们的利益，在她获释后，她最终能得到她显然迫切需要的治疗。”直到今天，没有人能确定
what motivated Sherry Papini to stage such an elaborate hoax. Some believe she was a narcissist who craved attention or that she wanted to be viewed as a hero. Others blame mental health issues, but various experts have struggled to come up with a diagnosis that would explain Sherry's actions. The fact that she was capable of planning and organizing such a ruse ruled out various conditions.
是什么促使雪莉·帕皮尼策划了如此复杂的骗局。有些人认为她是一个渴望关注的自恋者，或者她想被视为英雄。其他人则将其归咎于心理健康问题，但各路专家都难以得出一个能解释雪莉行为的诊断结果。她有能力策划和组织这样一场诡计的事实排除了各种情况。
One forensic psychologist who studied the case said, It is a mistake to assume mental illness is the cause of unusual behaviour. Regardless of Sherry's motivation, this wasn't a victimless crime. Financials aside, Sherry's actions had a detrimental impact on others. A spokesperson for the Shasta Keanu Latino community told the Sacramento Bee that Sherry's false narrative deeply impacted Latina women who were unfairly treated with suspicion. They said,
一位研究此案的法医心理学家说：“认为精神疾病是异常行为的原因是一个错误。”无论雪莉的动机是什么，这都不是一场没有受害者的犯罪。撇开经济因素不谈，雪莉的行为对他人的影响是破坏性的。沙斯塔基努拉丁裔社区的一位发言人告诉《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》，雪莉的虚假叙述深深影响了拉丁裔女性，她们受到了不公平的怀疑。他们说，
This incident instilled that fear in people and it didn't need to happen. As the sentencing judge stated, This case is serious and there have been very real harms to society. Victims of crimes may not believe they will be believed by law enforcement because of this hoax. Sherry Papini is a manipulator. It's not as if she has seen the error of her ways. If she had not been caught, she'd still be living the lie.
“这件事在人们心中灌输了恐惧，而这本不该发生。”正如判决法官所言：“此案性质严重，对社会造成了非常真实的伤害。由于这场骗局，犯罪受害者可能不再相信执法部门会相信他们。雪莉·帕皮尼是一个操纵者。她并没有意识到自己的错误。如果她没有被抓住，她现在还会生活在谎言中。”
Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢观看。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。